we will reopen the public hearing on a
house bill 324 representative Muirhead
welcome and apologies for the mix-up
last week
thank you very much and and no worries I
actually really uh appreciate the chance
to speak to the bill which I'm Prime
sponsor and uh really grateful for
um the chairs Indulgence of my absence
last week I apologize to the committee
for that
um this bill House Bill 324
um
tries to end the influence of
out-of-state Elites
in New Hampshire elections for governor
and executive Council
and it does that by allowing campaigns
for executive Council and governor in
state of New Hampshire to be funded
solely by voters in New Hampshire
chiefly through four 25 dollar
certificates
given to every registered voter
that they in turn can give to candidates
they support
voters become donors
but to qualify to receive those
certificates
candidates
have to show that they have real
Grassroots support
candidates for executive Council have to
get 500 donations of five dollars at
least five dollars no more than 125
dollars to qualify to receive those
voter dollars candidates for Governor
have to get twenty five hundred five
dollar donations that's a lot of door
knocking that's a lot of talking to your
neighbors talking to people in your
districts a lot of the retail politics
that people in the New Hampshire House
of Representatives understand how to do
after qualifying
candidates can accept camera you know
ask for can can invite voters to give
them the 25 certificates to finance
their campaign and they can continue to
raise small donations of between five
dollars and 20 125 for executive Council
five and 250 for governor
without limit
the candidates who win their primaries
would then receive an immediate sum
enough to let them run a viable general
election campaign
gubernatorial candidates win the primary
get a million dollars executive cancel
Council candidates will get sixty
thousand dollars so they could turn
around pivot after the primary and run
and run a viable
general election campaign
that's the plan that's what this bill
does
it's something different it's something
new it's
um
it's an idea
and it's a plan that's meant to address
a campaign Finance system that a whole
lot of people think is broken
a campaign Finance system that forces
candidates to genuflect to big donors
a campaign Finance system that gives
Elites and especially out-of-state
Elites too much power over who runs
over who gets nominated and over who
wins and I might just note that that
those qualifying small donations that I
mentioned the the the donations of say
five dollars that you have to get to to
qualify to receive voter dollars ninety
percent of those small donations have to
come from in-state voters in order to
qualify gotta call those don't small
donations have to come from New
Hampshire rights
in order to qualify to receive voter
dollars so this disempowers the the
Elites in the state of California who
who have a an awfully large appetite to
influence how things go in a state like
New Hampshire they lose their power
New Hampshire voters
are re-empowered
I worry that
ordinary citizens without connections to
the donor class
lose hope that they can run a viable
campaign for the higher offices in the
state they they fill the New Hampshire
House of Representatives and they serve
I'm I dare say with great distinction
in both parties in the New Hampshire
House of Representatives we know that an
amateur legislature works we know that
citizen legislators and citizen
officials bring real wisdom to public
decision making and and that's the
spirit I'd like to I'd like to open that
door the door that is open in the New
Hampshire house to the higher offices in
the state
right now as I mentioned
people know that they can't really run
for those higher offices
without
without taking on almost a full-time job
of begging out of Staters for money
that's a problem
it's a problem
that we can solve however
it's a problem that besets both parties
it disempowers voters on the left
disempowers voters on the right
and it disempowers voters who don't care
about the left or the right
it disempowers progressives it
disempowers Libertarians it disempowers
voters who don't care about ideology but
who just have common sense
and I think our politics needs more
people like that
this bill tries to re-empower Common
Sense it tries to open the door for
ordinary citizens in New Hampshire
people who know their neighbors who are
admired by their neighbors people who
are admired maybe because they coach
Youth Sports people who admired because
they're the sort of people in our towns
and cities who say yes when they're
asked to do something when when frankly
most people say no I'm too busy no I
can't
but those people who always they're the
go-to people and we all know who they
are and when people go to them they say
yeah I'm busy but I can do that I can
pitch in I'm ready though that's the
kind of Civic spirit that makes the
world turn it makes democracy work is
what I should say and and that's the
kind of those are the kind of people I'd
like to see be able to run for for
governor and have a viable chance of
winning
um now nothing is perfect in in politics
nothing's perfect in Practical there's
no like I don't know no bill no plan no
system is is God all is on the side of
the angels and and every plan has its
issues
um and one problem with this plan if you
haven't figured out already is that it's
not free
um it would cost money
to fund this plan
and that money would have to be
would have to come from from the
citizens of New Hampshire through some
sort of fee or tax it's too bad that
that's true but that is true and I
confess it I've calculated how much
money this plan would cost if
um all the primary candidates and all
the general election candidates fully
qualified and and and
we're successful attracting the the
voter dollars right up to the to the
limits
um which is sort of the high end of an
estimate and I've calculated it would
cost eight dollars per registered voter
per election cycle or four dollars per
registered voter per year
for some that will be too much to even
contemplate
I think for some who think that big
money and out-of-state Elites have too
much power in our politics eight dollars
an election cycle will seem like a
reasonable amount to spend
to to solve a fundamental problem
to me it seems like a bargain that's why
I'm sponsoring the bill
um a bipartisan study group led by Brad
cook a couple years ago looked into this
idea looked into what it would cost and
brainstormed a page or two of ideas
about how to fund it those ideas ranged
from slight increases in fees
such as motor vehicle fees or criminal
fees to a clean elections Lottery
um
one thing to note is that this bill
does not fund this system
this bill creates a legal framework for
the system
by funding it with one dollar so that
there's a line item in the state budget
that can be supplied if and when the
legislature in its wisdom at a future
point should decide that this plan is so
compelling that it wants to fund it in
the meantime it'd be funded through
fines on campaign Finance violations
fines I have to confess that I think I
might end up contributing to because I
missed a deadline
um but that that's not the funding plan
in in in the in the end it would have to
be fully funded by subsequent
legislation this bill explains the idea
lays out a framework for the idea
gives us the chance to explain the idea
to our constituents
and gives the legislature an opportunity
in the future to fully fund it if the
legislature so decides
foreign
the bill tries to bring full control of
New Hampshire elections to New Hampshire
voters
right now New Hampshire voters cast the
vote but they don't
provide the dollars
in every election there's a primary
before the primary
it's called the donor primary
and candidates have to compete in that
primary before they can actually
make a viable offer offer a viable
campaign to complete for votes this bill
tries to eradicate that donor primary
and give power back to New Hampshire
voters I hope I've been able to explain
the intentions and the and the
mechanisms of the idea and Mr chair I'd
be happy to take questions
thank you
thank you representative boehm
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
but we still have a problem but still
not going to prevent and that the U.S
Supreme Court ruled some years ago about
freedom of speech out of state
Pax
can still
Place ads with a lot of money can't they
there there would be especially you know
the campaigns that aren't connect uh ad
campaigns that aren't connected to any
particular campaign would continue to be
able to run by the way there's nothing
that would force candidates to opt into
the system so a candidate who wanted to
raise money in the traditional way by
going to out-of-state Elites would still
be able to do that so I think you're
right it's not like it bars all
political spending nor does it try to
um you know to to do an end run around
constitutional decisions that have said
people have the right to spend money on
political things nor does it borrow a
candidate who wants to raise money
in the way that candidates traditionally
have from continuing to do that so so I
think you're right it doesn't completely
eliminate the the influence of money in
politics what it does is get what it
tries to do is give ordinary citizens
who don't have access to that money but
who are admired by their neighbors a
chance to run a viable campaign
representative Kennedy
yeah I had basically the same question
because there's a lot of mention of
limiting the power of Elites but I don't
see that this does this in any way and
what it does do is it as you said it
lets a small guy maybe compete oh I'm
sorry
uh uh is that correct
but I appreciate both the commentary and
the and the question
um and I guess I my responsibility would
if someone were to say it doesn't do
that in any way I would descent and say
it does do that in some way it it limits
the power of money in some way in an
important way but it doesn't abolish it
it doesn't eliminate it so there's a lot
of space between
you know saying no money can be spent in
politics no private money can be spent
in products because we're going to
abolish the influence of money
completely and and saying that we're
going to
um change the system so those without
access to the donor class can run viable
campaigns and compete with those who are
The Darlings of the Dorner class on an
equal footing
and that's what this tries to do it
doesn't it doesn't say those with money
are now un you know not free to spend it
um to advance their political goals what
it does do is try to create an Avenue
for people who can elicit large numbers
of small donations who have the support
of ordinary people in their Community
who have a reputation because of the
lives they've lived it tries to enable
them
to run a viable campaign and compete
with others
who who maybe are just uh you know
running ads because they know 20 big
donors
representative Barry
um actually led up to my one of my
points so uh the cap for governor is a
million dollars
um in 2020
um Dr Tom Sherman raised one million 976
that Mill 1.976 million dollars Governor
cenini raised 2.163 million dollars
um this would give a million dollars
um so I guess my question is how did you
arrive at a million dollars and I can't
believe I'm going to utter these words
is that enough
no I think that's the right question to
ask because if it isn't then these
people aren't going to be able to run
viable campaigns competitive campaigns
so the million dollars is what a
candidate who qualifies and wins the
primary
um and shows up on a general election
ballot get to run in that general
election they also get to raise up to
420 000 in voter dollars those are the
25 certificates that of which each voter
gets four
and which each voter can give to
candidates of their choosing you could
give all four of your certificates to
one particular candidate running for
governor you could split them up among
different
um you know executive Council candidates
and gubernatorial candidates if you
wished
um so there's another four hundred and
twenty thousand dollars there there's
also small donations up to 250 dollars
the candidates can raise and we're not
limiting those
so so that's not just a million and we
are trying to set these numbers with
reference to what is required to run a
viable campaign
um and and I think uh I think these are
these are sufficient but
you know because of inflation things
like that they're going to change over
time
representative wood
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um I'm a little confused when you said
eight dollars per voter is it eight
dollars per voter eight dollars per
taxpayer
could you clarify that yeah thank you so
what I did was I just um sorry about the
speaker that's standing between us I
wish I could move it
um I calculated the the total cost
uh that would be involved if there were
competitive primaries in each of the
five executive council districts and in
the gubernatorial campaign and where
every single candidate a qualifies and
then B
successfully elicits voter dollars those
25 certificates right up to the cap
um which is as I said 420 000 for a
governor and it's 84 000 by the way for
an executive Council Canada and then
looked at you know both people
qualifying in the general election and
looked at the aggregate amount of money
it's about six million dollars and
divided by the number of registered
voters in the state and it's just a way
of of you know getting my mind around
how much it costs per registered voter
um it's a way of conveying that
um and I I had to make a bunch of
assumptions to do that I I tried to err
on the side of it you know
um I tried to build in all the costs I
could imagine and come up with the air
on the side of making the cost larger
rather than smaller
um and so anyway it's registered voters
it's not number of persons in the state
um it doesn't include people who aren't
registered or aren't able to register
something like that it's and that was
just the figure I took because I thought
that would I don't know thank you can I
have a follow-up be a good way of
putting it
we're gonna have to wrap this quick so
we can get to our next one it's quick
um you mentioned uh five to five hundred
dollars for donations and we need to
track this so if I if I get five dollars
from somebody I gotta get their name and
address is that how this works how are
we going to know they came from State
money or
yeah you're exactly right you're exactly
right so there's a Mr Burton for the
candidate and also for the state I also
tried to build in the administrative
costs which the which are contained in
the fiscal note in the estimate of the
of the per person cost and
um and and
you know let me just say in response so
again it's it's the the defect is that
it involves Administration and cost
um it's not free and it doesn't you know
just it's not self-executing
um
and uh and I can understand if somebody
says well the costs are too high and the
administered burden is too high and I
don't see it where I mean they're
reasonable people can disagree as as we
were talking about this morning
um
you know what I
would invite you to do is is try to
understand the idea you know
try to like I had to wrap my mind around
the idea see whether you think IT
addresses the problem whether you're for
it against it it's it's a it's a way of
trying to address something that a whole
lot of people say is a problem and
um and it's a way of doing it that I
think I just good faith don't think
Advantage is the left or the right or
any other group I think in both of our
great parties today we see a Grassroots
element and we see an Elite element and
we often see them you know not in
alignment and and and this is a chance
to give that or the ordinary citizens
um the voice that I think they deserve
thank you thank you Mr chair for the
follow-up
for the questions
there will only be two more
representative for Domo Brian
thank you Mr chairman I'm a little
confused about
how we would change over from
collecting fines for people with
campaign violations and in creating a
fund that way and then to what you say
is eight dollars per person how would
that exactly be collected from those
people who are paying the eight dollars
per registered voter do they pay it
state level county level local level pay
when they vote
how does that work
yeah thank you very much for the
question I appreciate a chance to
clarify that and I'll do it as quickly
as I can the the big idea is that it
would cost about six million dollars per
election cycle to run this and the state
could collect that six million dollars
any the legislature could decide to
collect it any way it chooses
and it's not literally going to go out
there and charge each voter eight
dollars to exercise their sacred right
to vote that's obviously not what it's
going to do it might decide to initiate
a lottery a clean elections Lottery that
would raise sufficient amount of money
um and and and fund this it might decide
to impose a fee that would raise a
sufficient amount of money on something
else
um and uh including you know raising
criminal justice fee there's lots of
ideas and uh an earlier
um
witness
Ms Bundy submitted a page or two of
ideas for funding this that the
bipartisan commission brainstormed a
couple years ago and I'm happy to
resubmit those
um to the committee thank you very
kindly and thank you Mr chair I really
appreciate uh yeah I really do
appreciate your letting me test me
testify this morning thank you so much
sure
for the questions
all right representative wood can you
pass up the blue sheet
all right both of the folks on the blue
sheet had also testified so
that Nets zero on the blue sheet and
closes the public hearing on House Bill
324.
did it
the next bill will be House Bill 482
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is we haven't opened
the hearing yet oh I'm sorry
we will open the public hearing on a
house built 482 representative pennick
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is um representative
Sandra Panic I'm from Pelham New
Hampshire I'm a ghost time on I believe
in election integrity and we all do
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to introduce this bill to you
this four points that we'd like to talk
about on this bill this bill will
require the it requires the Secretary of
State to select a major supplier to
print and deliver ballots for the
elections it makes certain that security
requirements are there for this ballots
and it specifies the chain of custody
for the ballots during and after the
election and it requires photocopied
proof of identity and residency when
submitting an absentee ballot a new poll
has been conducted
and published by ABC News this month
and it reaffirms that Americans faith in
the Integrity of our election system
remains very shaken with only 20 percent
of public of the public saying it's very
confident about the system
this is a citizen-wide issue
irrespective of a party
70 percent of the Democrats 80 percent
of The Independents and 80 87 percent of
the Republicans do not feel very
confident in the election process
we need to address that with some
fundamentals here in New Hampshire
New Hampshire plays a very unique role
in the country we are first in the
nation
and with this responsibility we should
be best in class in our election
practices
the bill we are bringing forward is to
strengthen our controls and increase
process transparency
this will result in improving the
Integrity of our election process and
instilling confidence and our election
results to our citizens and Country we
are asking three things to upgrade the
ballot technology
with the growth and the absentee ballots
it is imperative we upgrade our ballot
technology and make this part of our DNA
this includes reviews and
recommendations on improvements every
five years by the Secretary of State's
office
this bill would upgrade our paper
ballots to include watermarked paper
magnetic inks and other available tools
to prevent counterfeit ballots
two
tightening the business controls
centralized design and Supply your
selection of ballot printing with the
secretary of state and attorney general
enforce compliance of strict business
controls on the printing suppliers
selected by the New Hampshire by New
Hampshire who would be subject to
third-party audit and in 91a public
information disclosure
strictly control the number of ballots
printed issued and unused with stronger
reconciliation and chain of custody
requirements today absentee ballots are
not reconfiled and accounted for this
bill would require that all ballots
can be reconciled from the SOS purchase
order
to print it
to the towns and available to the public
to improve transparency and voter
confidence
see
separation of Duties with towns
certifying the total number of types of
ballots received and retained while the
Secretary of State manages the supplier
the specific ballot quantity type to be
ordered and audit auditable purchase
orders details that reconcile to the
towns
applications for an absentee ballot that
is not presented in person in the town
of city in which the applicant resides
shall include proof of identity and
residency with the application
clerks will work with close with the
voter polls voters until the polls are
closed when the ballots will be rejected
this will increase ballot security
ballots stored in boxes with
tamper-proof seals and Lock storage what
access controls implemented including
video surveillance and access laws logs
we respectfully ask the support of this
committee
of House Bill 482 to upgrade our
election practices here in New Hampshire
if you have any questions about this
bill
I am the vessel to deliver this
I would prefer that any questions be
given to Brenda town or to Deborah who
they have been very very involved in
this process and saw how the process
works and these are the expert
testimonies and thank you very much for
allowing me to deliver this message
thank you
thank you representative
Brenda town
um represent Panic we are going to need
a pink card from you before you go
is that good I feel so loud okay anyhow
thank you very much members of the
committee and Mr chairman for allowing
me to talk to this bill HP 482
um I am a long-term New Hampshire
resident and my name is Brenda town by
the way
um I'm a mother of four a grandmother of
nine my sons all serve in the military
and
um I am also professionally I am I've
got a Bachelor's degree in accounting
and finance a master's in international
finance and I was a division controller
of a billion dollar division for Hewlett
Packard and so my background is business
controls
and so I like to match those two
together because there's a professional
side of me and then there's this mom
grandma and so both of them are sitting
here in front of you today to talk about
why we need your help I'm in the state
of New Hampshire
so I participated in a Citizens audit
where
um we we've never audited the state by a
third party so the citizens decided to
take it upon themselves to go through
the process to see how our election
process was working and you know we
found a lot of things in the process
that brought this bill forward and so
what I'd like you to do is imagine if
you will our ballots were hundred dollar
bills
and if your ballot was worth a hundred
dollars or you're handing that out
would you in fact handle it the way that
we are currently handling it New
Hampshire and would you endorse and
support some of the recommendations that
this bill carries forward
so you'll see I left all of you this
beautiful colored copy which I apologize
for killing all these trees but has some
exhibits for you to walk through as we
walk through the parts of this bill
so as a controller and a financial
person when we would audit a large
corporation or even a small Corporation
we evaluate the business controls
because that's the Cornerstone of
Integrity for the business
the basic principles of business control
include the security of assets
separation of Duties traceability
reconciliation and audit and all those
components need to take place if you
will pass your audit by a third party
CPA and by the way if you don't you are
not allowed to trade on the New York
Stock Exchange you must be certified
so first the first picture you see is a
picture of security
um this bill asks the state of New
Hampshire to upgrade the way that we
handle our our ballots these pictures
were splashed all over the national news
when we conducted the Windham audit you
can clearly see that we're using reused
cardboard boxes that have been re-taped
reused with available with open gaps and
they have multiple colored tapes on the
boxes including the sides which could
have easily been split open and re-taped
doesn't exude confidence if you were to
put your own money in there so again
this type of storage was seen over and
over again in all of the recounts that
we did this past year
so again a critical part of this
um the second piece is separation of
Duties you're going to find in this bill
that we've asked that the Secretary of
State create a purchase order for the
printer of our ballots after they select
them and qualify them in that purchase
order should have the line item detail
by town of how many ballots they ordered
how many in person how many absentee how
many tests and how many overprints were
available
that's not available today we have no
idea by town the exact amount of
purchase that was made by town and how
many of the the specific towns received
I've gone through a lot of the
documentation in that information is not
readily available it's quite often when
you go to the printer they'll see you'll
see a shipping document that says ship
per Karen LED and that I can provide
that data so upgrading that would be
very important for traceability we'll be
able to go back and see how many the
Secretary of State who has the
responsibility today and would have in
the future for ordering the quantity of
ballots that the printer would then ship
to the supplier I mean to the to the
towns again the reason for this is a
basic tenant in business you want to
separate responsibilities so like a
bookkeeper you would never allow you to
your bookkeeper to take checks in cash
the check checks and then reconcile the
bank account that goes with those checks
you would separate those
responsibilities not that anything is
actually bad going on but you want to
prevent the opportunity so we're
recommending that we separate that and
today the secretary of state orders
picks the supplier orders the ballots
cuts the purchase orders receives the
ballots then reships them to towns and
there's a lot of play in the number of
ballots which is my next point which
hopefully by providing some separation
we can create a little bit more
Integrity into the process
um the next thing I want to talk about
is traceability
so if you look at your next page I don't
know how many of you have been in the
bowels of the election process but I've
included for you a copy of a moderator
certificate every town signs off the
receipt of their ballots and they report
them on this moderator certificate
you'll notice that what's highlighted in
Orange is the only quantity of ballots
that any town certifies are there
in-person ballots no Town anywhere in
the state of New Hampshire certifies the
number of absentee ballots received so
you've got a gap at the printer and now
you've got a gap at the town
you'll notice that on the next page I've
provided you a copy and I apologize I
couldn't get the same election year so
you've got a 2020 a 2022 but the concept
is the same
on the night of an election the town
clerk will complete a moderator's
worksheet and they use as their starting
number
you'll look at that that's line one of
the ballot inventory you'll see that
they take the number of the moderator
certificate this number represents only
the in-person ballots they do not
reconcile the quantity of absentee
ballots received there's no receipt
information there's no leftover
information there's no information
reported on how many ballots weren't
returned now I know that information is
available but if you're trying to audit
something you want the ins and the outs
and unfortunately we don't have that
today and this must be remedied I'll get
a little bit onto that in a minute a
little bit further as you pace through
my really long deck and I apologize I
wanted to give you another couple of
examples about traceability and control
um and an audit of a small Bedford
um a special election a candidate lost
by 35 votes
when um the reconciliation was done with
the town there were actually more votes
that were cast than were reported
actually shipped by the Secretary of
State's office to the town so upon
further review there were a few things
found the first image here shows
shipments to the town of Bedford both
quantity of 150 both on the same
purchase order so there was a duplicate
shipment making a total of 300 invoices
instead of just 150.
in addition the auditor was able to
review with her 98 1A privileges the
actual shipments to the town that were
available in a separate file at the
Secretary of State's office what she
discovered is that there were additional
approximately 200 extra ballots that
were what are called overruns so when a
printer does a run of ballots they
sometimes end up inadvertently printing
extra ballots to ensure like when
they're running it they want the ink to
make sure it's nice and it's and it's
high quality so sometimes there's extra
prints in this particular case the
printer had printed a lot of extra
overruns and those overruns were shipped
to the town but not traced or tracked or
added to the total it was not discovered
until a Reconciliation was done on the
official number of ballots shipped to
the town versus what was cast versus
what we had in extra files now I know
everyone's super busy and we don't have
standard practices so again the nature
of this bill is to upgrade our ability
on tracking these
the next sheet I want to show you also
talks about the necessity for tracking
ballots
so our absentee ballots as I just
demonstrated with the moderator
checklist and certification do not track
the total number of absentee ballots
so for because I'm a crazy auditor
spreadsheet not I went out to the
Secretary of State's website and I
downloaded the 2020 in the 2022 actual
ballots cast and through the 91a process
we were able to collect how many ballots
the Secretary of State ordered from the
printer
in the 2020 election what we discovered
is that there were 270 sorry 247
000 absentee ballots that were untracked
untraced and uncounted that's on a base
of about 814
000 voters
that represents 23 percent of all votes
cast had uncast untracked absentee
ballots
when you carry that forward to the
midterm you'll see the midterm numbers
below there is a hundred and four
thousand seven hundred and fifty five
ballots that again went untracked
untraced in our midterm now I do also
want to remind you that towns have the
ability to print their own ballots if
they decide that they need some backup
ballots or they can use absentee ballots
to backfill if they run short
so this is kind of a wild card in the
process and we need to close the gap it
just completely exposes us as a state to
a huge huge area of malfeasance as well
as it's actually an opportunity to have
a lot of error
um
we've included another part to this
ballot which I think more people will be
a little bit concerned about just
because of the the nature of it but I
actually as a as a accountant think that
it's important we've introduced the
concept of ordering your absentee ballot
online to make it easy for the voter and
I am completely all for that
but you can order that ballot unlike in
the past where you would have to go into
the town and ask for a ballot
in the case where you can order online
there's no validation that you are who
you say you are
if we're using birth date my audit team
that performed a lot of this work was
very simply able to get birth date
information on a lot of the websites
that sell that information so as a state
in this absentee ballot process that we
have in place now we've introduced a lot
of risk so the recommendation in this
bill is if please go ahead and make a
make an application online for your
absentee ballot you know that makes it
much more easy for a person at home but
snap a picture of your license and
upload that along or an ID or proof of
Dominic style so that we know that you
are who you say you are especially with
the number of absentee ballots that are
floating around
the final thing that I leave with you is
just a picture of three examples over
the past two years where we made the
news for out of control ballots
and these were just small samples but
when I come back and talk to you this
afternoon about the audit I will be able
to give you much bigger examples but I
just for this piece this is strictly
about business controls this is strictly
about common sense it's all about
putting our votes into the same category
we would cash in a same expectations we
would have on our investments and when
we put money in the bank
so I really appreciate your time and I'd
be glad to take any questions
thank you
representative Howard
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
for coming and testifying today uh so if
you wouldn't mind pulling up the amended
version of the bill uh if you could help
me uh clarify lines 27 uh and 28 uh the
envelopes and ballots shall be subject
to the order of the body to which the
person which such person claims to be
elected
uh this this isn't the whole sentence
but could you uh clarify what that
statement means
sorry I'm just grabbing a copy of that
could you test tell me where to look uh
lines 27 and 28
um
on what page because I'm I it's it's on
the first page it's the amended version
do you have that
um
I don't have that sorry
hold up now
we don't have an amendment we're here
hearing the bill
I'd be happy to to to field that
question when the amendment is brought
forward I just don't have a copy of it
and I know that was added after I
drafted this part so I apologize
otherwise I'd be glad to answer it for
you all right thank you thank you
representative boom thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking the question
one thing reading the bill I see the
problem
testing right now this town clerk gets
gets the balance they take a sample of
the ballot not testing balance regular
balance and use them for testing
machines is that a mistake in your in
the bill no they they should be able to
get a copy of these identical ballots to
test in the machines to qualify the
machines
so they should be printed and available
for the town to do their testing
follow-up but shouldn't the testing be
done on the actual ballots not on quote
quote test balance
so today all our machines are are
processed with test ballots so a town
we'll put test ballots through in order
to evaluate the efficacy of the machine
so this was meant to cover that issue
did I not answer your question I just
want to make sure I do no because the
testing being done today by rules given
by the Secretary of State
we're going to move on
further questions
representative
thank you for taking my question
and requires the Secretary of State to
supply
Select A supplier to print and deliver
ballots and make certain security
requirements is there any other state
that does this that you know of I know
many states have outsourced this
activity to third parties like I can
just cite Arizona right now using
runbeck
um I like the way that this bill was
drafted because it gives the control to
our secretary of state but it also puts
in place the requirement for a third
party audit on that supplier
to ensure that they're executing to the
processes this is kind of what we do in
the business world
um
and just looking over the bill on page
four of the regular bill
does this mean
that I can choose and pick where I want
to vote where it says
he or she desires to vote
do you see
procedure of by applicant an application
form
of an absentee ballot shall be mailed or
delivered to any person who applies
therefore
to the any town or city clerk it shall
be filled out by the applicant and sent
to the clerk of the town or city in
which he or she desires to vote
so that is the existing text and they
inserted the requirement
um at the bottom any applicant so that
is what is in place today so this bill
did not modify that and I believe the
intention is if I live in East Wakefield
and my intention is to vote on East
Wakefield I'll go into that office and
request an absentee ballot
further questions
thank you Mr um chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm looking at the second or third
page it's the moderators worksheet
you mentioned that there wasn't an
accounting for the state absence he
ballots but there's a line on there for
State absentee balance cast right so so
to go ahead please finish I was going to
say so are you so could you just clarify
what you meant when you referred to the
absentee ballots and we're not getting a
picture the correct picture of the
numbers sure so what happens is let's
say a town receives 10 000 absentee
ballots
but only 2 000 people vote the 2 000
people who voted will appear on this
worksheet they're part of the
reconciliation that tie out to the
machine count and the return of vote
that the town does
the other 8 000 ballots
they can be used as airplanes they can
be saved and uncast they could have been
used to backfill although it will show
on this sheet on you'll notice on that
that same sheet and this is very
important as well about business
controls you'll notice that there is a
line that allows let's see it says
subtract
official election day ballots and then
below it it says add photocopy or
absentee ballots cast
um as official ballots so a town has the
purview to pull out of that absentee
ballot quantity and stick it in with
people who need to vote in person or
they can make the other choice and go
print them in their own
um you know their own facility and so
again that's another big Escape in the
process because you really don't know
did they use absentee ballots did they
use printed ones and then you can
because you don't have the starting
number you can't reconcile and that's
why when I told you we have 247
000 ballots from 2020 that nobody can
really tell us
how they were used where they were used
where they are
that's a huge problem and it starts at
the devil's always in the detail
unfortunately and when you get start to
audit
you start to find these gaps in process
I hope I answered your question you do
thank you okay
further questions
all right thank you
okay so and this is your third swipe at
it for the committee's information we
still have one two
three to go the and previous ones the
request of time to speak was five
minutes it was more like 15. when this
public hearing was done I intend to take
a short break and roll straight into the
executive sessions
and whether or not the committee gets
lunch today depends on how fast you can
exec five bills because the other public
hearing will start at one o'clock
so you still want another swing at it
I think it's important
can I
ask my question
thank you thank you um on page five
section two the moderator finds the
absentee voter has not included a
photocopy document submission to a show
residency in the identification
so then the moderator can call the
the voter prior to closing of the
election
so that person has to go there and show
that's the or they can provide a an
email photo they there's there's a again
when you're trying to get an absentee
ballot
you wouldn't typically go into the Town
Clerk and request it and then ask but
we've changed the law so that now folks
can ask online and by doing that you've
disqualified your ability to confirm
that the asker is who they say they are
and so the only mechanism that we have
is to confirm with an identification
and we would do that if we were asking
you know doing banking they're going to
ask us for an idea if we're going to do
a withdrawal
all right thank you thank you very much
good morning Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Deb Rue I live in um
I've been a resident of New Hampshire my
whole life I'm currently in Manchester
and I thank you for the opportunity to
discuss HB 482 which I am in full
support of I come to you from the
background of being a mom and customer
service and sales are my background so
I've done a lot of talking with people
and I know
um
I ask a lot of questions and
um I had no idea two years ago when I
got involved in this whole process where
I would would end up and um what I would
end up focusing on but for today I want
to focus on
um number three on the first page of
this bill specifies the chain of custody
for ballots during and after an election
I volunteered at the polls for the
primary and 2022 general election for
the first time this year
and like I said I wanted to understand
the process I just didn't want to
understand my my own little job of I
shouldn't even say little but of
checking in people I wanted to know the
rest of the process and I was quite
surprised when I started asking
questions people didn't want to answer
them
um they're like you don't need to know
that it's not your place which made me
want to ask more questions so I actually
got an opportunity to um
to view the Evans printing company that
we currently use for printing our
ballots and one of the things that
really concerned me and um was there was
this cage a three-sided cage with boxes
for every town and in those boxes were
the overruns of absentee ballots the
ballots that no one ordered or requested
they were just there in case the town or
city clerk felt the need felt they would
be running low for people that came in
for further requests so they just have
these ballots standing there they
weren't locked there was it was only
three sides
um and they were right next to the
printing machines and so I asked the
manager there Bob like why don't you
have these in a room with lock and key
and why aren't they secured and and what
have you and he basically said don't
worry the building's locked at night so
they're not going anywhere
so I wasn't really comfortable with that
answer so I called him back and asked
them a lot more questions and he
basically said my chain of custody was a
locked building
and again that that just didn't sit very
well with me so um
I started asking questions of my own
town clerk and I said can you tell me
where you
capture the total number of apps and be
absentee ballots that you receive from
the Secretary of State
um and he said he doesn't and I said
well why not and he said because it's
not required by law
and I'm like well that's just
a strange answer because why wouldn't
you want to know
and reconcile the absentee ballots you
do it for the general election ballot so
why not the absentee ballots
and instead of him like giving me the
customer service that I'm kind of that
I'm used to giving to my to my customers
he started asking me drilling me why do
I want to know why why am I so concerned
about what happens to these absentee
ballots and again I come to you from the
point that I've taken Constitution
classes I've learned why my forefathers
came to this country I know what it
means to be a Biblical citizen I know
that it's my duty
as a voter and as a resident of New
Hampshire to help and and point out
things when I see questions that I I
want to get answers to and my own city
clerk is not wanting to give me answers
and hear what I'm saying it's it's not
even just hearing it's like
understanding and having it sink in to
make sense that what we're asking
doesn't really even need to be a law
it's just common sense like any business
would track their inventory like I put
an example in my my testimony here that
if you have a shoe store they're not
gonna
count the inventory of every shoe except
for the Nike shoes they're not going to
just leave those out like so why would
we do that with our absentee ballots and
again as Brenda said with a bank why a
bank doesn't just count the ones fives
and tens and leave the 20s to chance
and it's it's just common sense like we
need to have
chain of custody that me as a voter not
going and trying to accuse My Town Clerk
of any mishaps or any you know
any wrongdoing but I'm I just want to
see the paper it's my right as a citizen
I'm a voter and as we know voters have
consequences whoever gets elected can
affect my job can affect my children can
affect the money that I the
discretionary money so my vote is
important as is all of yours and all
we're asking in um is that we can see
where our votes and our our ballots are
going that's that's the bottom line here
so I did provide you with some examples
as well
um
so for instance on the moderator
worksheet as Brenda
mentioned the line item four we just
want like more transparency why can't we
have a 4A and B and add you know total
number of photocopied ballots cast and
total number of absentee ballots cast as
a fictional election day ballots because
like Brenda said you can use those for
official ballots if you run low
at the moment on the moderator's
worksheet as was already talked about we
only talk about cast ballots we don't
talk about anything about the total
number of absentee ballots received so
we can do the same thing add you know
line items there and this exhibit B was
really crazy for me
um in talking with my clerk he provided
me with because I'm in Ward 12 he
provided me with all of the ward 12
sheets for the process that they use for
checking in the general election ballots
why can't we just use another sheet like
this one and have it for absentee
ballots because when they receive the
boxes as I saw from the printer company
someone is hired on a temporary basis to
work at the printing company to do the
shipping of the ballots and when they
ship the ballots on the box it has the
total of the ballots inside so when you
get the general election ballots you
write on the sheet you count and you
verify that there's 100 in that box they
don't do that for the absentee ballots
why can't we just duplicate this sheet
and put absentee ballots on there
on the next sheet on the moderator
certificate it it says in there it says
excluding absentee ballots and ballots
used to test electronic ballot counting
devices why are we excluding our
absentee ballots from being certified
it just doesn't make sense to me so I'm
recommending that we
we up we change that or add you know the
line items for absentee ballots in there
because we need to certify those as well
and then I went in
um created a
a chart with the help of my friend
Brenda
um like a spreadsheet that the clerks
could adopt to help
you know
track are absentee ballots absentee
ballot reconciliation sheet it's very
simple it's it's not anything like
that's hard to follow I I just don't
understand why we we don't have this
right now because basically what I'm
trying to explain
is an equation that I kind of put
um here for everybody to easily
understand we're looking for the total
number of verified and certified
absentee ballots that we get because
they can get them from the Secretary of
State just ships them out or they can
request additional ones that are in that
unsecured cage that's just sitting in
the middle of the printing company so I
want that total and you subtract all
absentee ballots that are requested so
we have different categories of people
that request absentee ballot so we want
that total requested that were used
to be subtracted from what was received
and that gets the total number of unused
absentee ballots and then someone after
the election after the polls close will
actually go to the stack of unused
absentee ballots count them up
and that total which would be D will
equal C and if they don't then we need
to find out what happened and where they
went and if they do then you just put
the absentee ballots in a box secure it
right on the top you know the total and
say that these are the unused absentee
ballots and then they're put away for
the 22 months
and that's all I'm asking you to really
consider and just go through the thought
process that I'm I'm coming from like
customer service and a caring
point of view I I just love our state
and I I I appreciate our elections like
I've never appreciated them before I
know the work that goes in it I
understand the long days I was there
from 5 to 11 30. you know I I get it and
a lot of what I hear from you know the
town clerks it's it's just excuses there
we don't need everybody is overworked I
mean you you look at like Brenda you
know in the in the industry that she's
in I have a friend that works in account
receivables they're overworked everybody
is overworked that's not that's not a
reason to not do this important stuff
you know we all like you said you may
not get lunch today we're all overworked
and we're doing our best and I'm just
here to help I want to help I want to I
want to dig in I want to do the work and
I want to secure it and increase the
confidence in my elections and this
process will do that this will will
greatly do that so I appreciate your
time and I I thank you for for listening
to me
does anybody have any questions thank
you are there questions from the
committee
all right thank you okay thank you
Michael O'Brien
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael O'Brien I
am a lobbyist with party strategies here
on behalf of America votes today
um I'm going to make this quick as to
try not to stop you from your lunch I'll
go directly to page four line 16 where
it talks about any excuse me any
application for an FC ball that is
presented in person the town or city in
which the applicant resides to include
proof of identity and residency we've
seen versions of this bill I think every
year or this part of this bill anyway
every year for the past 10 years or so
that I've been in front of this
legislature
um
this obviously has a pretty big problem
to it which is that absentee ballots are
often accessed by some of our most
vulnerable communities homebound seniors
um folks who don't have access to
printers faxes copy machines other
things that would make it possible for
them to then be able to access an
absentee ballot and uh and use it and so
even though I do appreciate that there
is
um an attempt to cure it here there's no
pre-processing in this bill and so
you're attempting to cure on Election
Day
um which obviously is already frantic
and hectic and we don't cure ballots on
Election Day because the moderators uh
or whoever is handling the ballots don't
have time to then find the voter record
give them a call hopefully to get in
touch with them maybe they do maybe they
don't et cetera which is why we don't
cure here to begin with and so while
this is in the bill it doesn't solve the
problem so that's really the part of the
bill I wanted to touch on make this as
quick as possible I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you questions from the committee
all right thank you very much
deputy secretary Hennessey
and Company
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State and with me is Aaron Hennessey
deputy secretary of state and initially
uh
deputy secretary Hennessey was going to
make the remarks on this bill but after
listening to the testimony I I thought
it's important that I step in and just
make a few comments uh about the state
of our elections
um I I think what we're seeing
in the testimony and the legislation
this session is a clash of the way our
elections have developed over a couple
of centuries
and the way some people would like to
see the elections happening at the
current time where the expectation is
perfection and accountability in terms
of reconciliation and just making sure
that everything matches uh everything
else
and I can tell you that that would be a
very difficult thing to achieve in our
election process and to get there would
be incredibly expensive
the reason for that is
the legislature determines the policy on
how our elections run
and in doing that
the legislature elects Secretary of
State to conduct those elections and the
secretary of state is elected for a
two-year term and if you don't like the
way the job is performed or the way
election was run you can change that
person and put put somebody else in
place that you think can do a better job
because of that
I think any Secretary of State and
certainly the way I feel wants to be
accountable to you I don't want to have
to farm stuff out to third-party vendors
to do the job that I've been charged to
do because if they fail I fail and I
want to make sure that I
am responsible for every step in the
process that is related to an election
and that's the way it is right now and I
would uh
discourage vehemently farming ballot
Printing and ordering off to third-party
vendors that then send the ballots to
the individual towns because I lose the
ability to make sure that we're doing
the job in the best way for New
Hampshire
there is a lot that goes into the
printing process and I think it's
important that all of you see it and I
guess the invitation that I would make
right now is that when we start printing
the ballots for the presidential
primaries sometime next month
um
that uh that you come to the Press uh
and see how that operation works because
it is different than what you have heard
in testimony here today
and there's flexibility that is needed
in that process as well for example
um
we print ballots from the printer prints
the ballots let me just say this too we
use a local printer
the printer The Print Shop is located in
Bow
and that works really well for us
because when we have to deal with last
minute issues uh let's say if a
candidate passes away and we have to
change the name on a ballot or we find a
mistake where about a candidate's name
was spelled improperly or wrong that we
have to fix that very quickly
um and we reprint ballots when those
things happen and so we have to have a
really good working relationship with
the Press
and we have staff
at the site during the time that the
ballots are being printed and the staff
there are the ones that take the ballots
for each town make sure each town is
getting the right ballots puts them in
the boxes properly seal them and make
sure that they get shipped to the
individual cities in town so we have an
on-site presence while ballots are being
printed I know that when ballots are
being printed there's a sign in log for
anybody that visits the press to have to
sign in when they enter and when they
leave
and the building is locked so it is
secure and we make sure that that is the
case
getting back to the ballots we print the
ballots on large sheets of paper they
might be almost the size of this table
and on each sheet of paper we will print
ballots for different towns on that same
sheet of paper
and because different towns have
different populations and need different
numbers of ballots there are always
overrun ballots that come out of that
process and those are securely capped
you know inside the facility the print
facility
and distributed to towns if if they feel
like they're running low on ballots and
that happens a lot with absentee ballots
they usually don't run out but they get
nervous when they get low and so we will
ship additional absentee ballots
um
we know and keep track of the number of
ballots that we ship to each Town
whether they're official ballots or
whether they are absentee ballots
we know on the moderators worksheets how
many ballots were used in the election
how many bullets were cast in the case
of absentee ballots those ballots are
processed on Election Day when the
moderator opens the affidavit envelope
that actually contains uh the ballot of
that voter
um in the case of test ballots each town
is given 50 official ballots
upon which they're supposed to write
tests at the top of each ballot before
they use them so that they can be
identified as test ballots but their
actual ballots that get run through and
test the machines
the the people that really run the
elections are the local election
officials who we all elect in our cities
and towns to do the the job
uh that's a local level and we put Faith
in those individuals to do the job but
you know some of them are highly
qualified to do it others are just
learning and so it's a very human
process when we're dealing with
thousands of local election officials
the system is not designed to run like a
business where you can put all of these
controls in place I have no authority
over uh
the local election officials other than
help train them and you know teach them
uniform standards on what we're looking
for elections the Attorney General's
office is the enforcement Authority if
they break the law and if they are
negligent then you know there are steps
that can be taken to deal with that but
I am not their boss in the polling place
they have the responsibility and statute
to do with the statute instructs them to
do
and so you know we see we see very human
problems coming out of polling places
Windham is the unfortunate uh uh
stepchild not stepchild but poster child
of you know things that can go wrong uh
in in a polling place and we learn from
that and it's not to say that we can't
do do things better we know that we can
and we're working on those many of the
proposals coming out of this committee
um are things that you know we encourage
and will work on but it's a joint effort
bottom line is we have to be able to
have confidence in the results of the
election and I think you know
for as long as I've been in New
Hampshire
we run elections really well and I think
we have a reputation for doing that we
have not had any major significant
failures in the election process
like we see in other states and I think
that's that's a tribute to the way that
we conduct the activities here so I'm
going to stop there and let Aaron talk
about the specifics of the bill if she
wants to after that but and I'd be happy
to answer any questions when she's done
okay thank you Mr secretary and thank
you members of the committee there's a
few points that I just want to comment
on and one um kind of working backwards
to forwards was representative hamer's
question about the
um the proof of identity
um the way that
um and I'm sure you already know this
but sorry for repeating when you request
an absentee ballot this bill would
require you to provide proof of identity
that absentee ballot request is then
processed by your city or town clerk So
in theory you wouldn't get an absentee
ballot unless you had provided that
information already so that the
moderator wouldn't have to check that on
the back end of the election day
um in the beginning of the bill it talks
about changes to updating of the actual
paper used in the election and
um the secretary has already looked into
options of this including secure Inc and
perhaps
um using official Watermark seals on the
ballot paper themselves and that's
something that we're open to and there's
options out there just recognize that
that would cause an increase in the
actual printing process itself for the
paper
um
see my notes
um we um the Secretary of State's office
has a working relationship with
Secretary of States across the country
so I reached out to our organization on
the locked ballot containers themselves
to see if there's any other states that
use those at this time and
um no other state currently has the
requirement to use a locked box right
now we use the you got some pictures of
the cardboard boxes that we use
um there there are states that require
locked ballot storage which is what New
Hampshire already does that requires
that locally and at the state level we
do that but to have a locked container I
don't know what the cost would be for
that I just want to recognize that
um I think I showed you the different
sizes of our ballots previously so those
containers would have to come in
different sizes and then the the
managing of those specific containers
might be very cumbersome just because of
the size of that they would be both at
the state level and at the local level
so there might be different storage
options that your local communities
would have to invest in for that
um and I don't know the cost of what
that would be because no other state is
currently requiring that whether they
some local
counties or local cities or towns do
that already I don't know the answer to
that yet so I'm still looking into it
um
I think that's all I have to add right
now and I know I do know that in the
fiscal note the municipal Association
did say that there's a big expense for
local communities to add oversight of
the ballot storage via video
surveillance
um
and
the um
as a former or still licensed but a CPA
and somebody who's to do internal
control Consulting for a living I do
want to say that the the business audit
that this requires of the printer
May deter printers from actually wanting
to print our ballots going forward it's
very vague and it might be very
cumbersome for an external audit company
to come in look at all of their business
controls which would include HR
um I mean if any anything to do with a
business would be included in a business
control audit and be cumbersome for the
vendor and also
um under the right to know law and
expose a lot of information that a
private small company in New Hampshire
might not want to have public knowledge
too
and I I just wanted to add one example
of the need to be flexible
um going back to the sheets of paper I
usually order uh paper for ballots many
months before the election and knowing
that there were concerns about supply
chain issues I had ordered
the ballot paper for the 2022 election
a year before in the fall and as we got
into the spring
excuse me we were hearing from the
printer that the paper supplier was
saying that
we can't guarantee that you're going to
have paper for ballots uh
um So that obviously caused some major
concern we ended up doing a couple of
things one we went to a local pulp Mill
paper mill in New Hampshire uh Monadnock
paper and asked them if they would be
able to produce a custom order of paper
that would fit the uh that could be used
in the ballot counting devices that we
use and we were able to get a a order of
paper from that for that purpose but we
also in the last election decided to use
both sides of the ballot to reduce the
amount of paper that we needed to use
just so that we could manage a potential
paper shortage it was a national issue
it wasn't just New Hampshire in the end
there was enough paper to to do the job
but those are the types of things that
that get thrown at you that you need
complete flexibility in dealing with
that and I'm not sure that a third party
vendor in that situation would have had
the same skill or luck that we had in
that process so we're happy to answer
any questions
thank you questions from the committee
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you
um in regards to the ballot security
during the election I have a question
what happens to the ballots when they
are kicked out of the machine
I'm sorry I didn't hear the last part of
that what happens to the ballot when it
is kicked out from the machine when the
machine refuses to receive it so the the
legislature passed a law requiring that
ballots that the machine reads as
overvoted
get returned back to the voter the
ballot is then taken and but by the vote
are supposed to be placed in the side
pocket of the machine so that it can be
hand counted at the end of the night at
any ballot that's rejected by a voting
machine would be hand counted at the end
of the night
excuse me I have a follow-up
um was it recommended from the Secretary
of State's office during training for
the local officials to place the kicked
out ballot into an open box if a side
ballot
um
pocket wasn't available
if a side pocket available was not
available for some reason then we would
our training would say that they should
get a cardboard box you know put a hole
in the top of it and place ballots in
there that's the same advice that would
be given if a ballot accounting device
breaks down for some reason and to keep
the line from getting really long you
know we encouraged the moderator to do
the same setups so the voters can put
their ballots in a box and then they can
be fed through the machine later once
it's up and running
further questions thank you
representative Lane
thank you Mr chair thank you
um are there suggestions in the bill
that you would support
um or that you think are uh eat more
easily implemented
um
first of all you know I think that it's
the security and the ballot there are
inks special links that can be used now
in fact you know I'm not sure if Wendell
Smith is here today but he has a a DNA
you know synthetic DNA product that is
basically invisible link
that the ballot counting machines may be
configured to be able to read or if you
use a special light you can see it
there's special magnetic inks that could
be used
uh Watermark paper could be purchased in
those big sheets provided that there's a
supply of them out there to get so I
mean things like that we would be open
to obviously there's an additional cost
involved in doing something like that
and and that's not to say that some of
the uh
you know the the reconciliation measures
and things that are proposed in the bill
aren't worth taking a look at and trying
to do a better job with
um
New Hampshire has come a long way since
I've been in in the Secretary of State's
office for 20 years
when I first started in 2002 we had a
set of statutes but there was not a lot
of uniform training going on
cities and towns were doing elections in
different ways they were all keeping
their own unique checklist we didn't
have a standard Statewide
checklist then and you know you travel
around the states and you would see the
way some election officials were
conducting the election in the polling
place and when you question them about
it they said well that's the way we've
always done it it didn't matter what the
statute said at the time so we've gotten
away from that and you know the polling
places are pretty uniform now but you
know every now and then we'll find one
where the you know the traditional way
of doing it still still lingers since we
deal with that but um
yeah I mean we keep we keep making
progress and we keep making improvements
and we're open to them
so before you do that so the committee
is aware I do not believe that probably
the 15 or 20 minutes we have is going to
be time to get these executive sessions
done so what we will do is when this
public hearing is over we will do what
we can recess the rest until 3 30 today
go ahead all right thank you would you
need a statute to do the ink or to do
those Provisions do you do you need a
statute to allow you to do that
it would be helpful to
authorize the use of security measures
on the ballot
further questions
representative hammer
our election officials sworn in
yes
anyone else
thank you Mr secretary thank you
secretary
all right representative wood can I have
the blue sheet please
yep it was on the wrong pile
thank you Mr chair Nate Chris from
Municipal Association we we oppose this
legislation
um based on the cost basis
and deferral all the process questions
the Secretary of State's office
um I did contribute to a fiscal note
um and basically what I'm looking at is
page three lines 16 through 18.
um that as described would basically
treat uh the ballots in their containers
uh at the local level essentially with
the same kind of security you'd expect
in a bank vault
um that's not what the law currently
requires
I know that the secretary has answered a
number of questions about the process so
I would just add that last year the
legislature modified the the process for
keeping ballots the local level it did
not require that video monitoring but
there is a visitor log process and a
sealing process and that's all based on
I believe long-standing practice adopted
from the election procedure manual
um and so I just want to point out that
it'd be very costly to put in that those
video recording systems I'm not aware of
any municipalities having those uh for
the purpose of looking at the storage
area for ballots they may be incidental
and that they have security cameras
around the building but nothing directly
geared towards this and there's no
appropriation in here so ultimately that
would be an additional cost for
municipalities which of course they'd
have to raise through taxation from the
taxpayers so we're concerned about that
additional cost especially because
realistically if you're going to put in
the cameras for this purpose you also
need to have someone review them and
that's not addressed in the legislation
either I'm happy to take any questions
thank you questions
thank you all right
Wendell Smith
thank you much uh yes uh Wendell Smith
is my name pollstar limited consultants
in security printing
um I've been in this business for 40
years now and
um one of the greatest things that has
come along in the last five years
uh developed because of my
activities watching this process go on
in Enfield where I live and love and
seeing what are the risks and troubles
that need to be overcome
the same time
one of the companies in this field
DNA Technologies which I'm connected to
sometimes and I have been Consulting
over 40 years in this space visiting
with everyone involved many governments
trade associations and what I have found
is what you know well that most
anti-counterfeiting answers
do not really work at the end unless the
people involved in the project
believe and trust
the system and in this case the absentee
ballot itself
so what's remarkable about DNA is it has
become obvious to all of us that it is
better than a fingerprint
it is reliable it lasts forever
if you will literally and we we no
longer use in this business several
companies are doing this worldwide and
I'd like to express that very quickly
and have it seen in another time in the
materials that I Supply to you so
we and others have been putting DNA not
originally human DNA like artists
enjoyed the prospect
it's no longer human DNA we're not
trying to identify a person with it it
is a synthetic DNA made for the purpose
of in this case
the absentee ballot itself and every
piece of envelope instructions
[Music]
will be marked with a New Concept that
puts DNA instead of onto an object for
any counterfeiting onto a piece of paper
so watching the process work and
recognizing this new development
there is a process in which
the paper
is marked before Printing and before use
with invisible DNA and other
UV or visible invisible lights that can
identify it for you and marked in areas
that are going to later be important
like where is this going to be marked or
signed and um
later on as the printer
prints this
pre-dna marked paper
with whatever is to be said or needed
that Mark the the invisible marks may be
behind some of the printed areas maybe
on a space where the name is going to be
signed later or not the name in The Case
of the absentee ballot there's no
reference in either the DNA or in this
process which provides any
access to who it is it's getting it so
this married into the global system of
tracking things including the U.S post
office and others having become
absolutely the Workhorse the most
important part of the process is it is
tracked reliably to where it goes
and with a cell phone or a more
expensive device but not needed
it's tracked just as your packages are
from every company and every post office
in the world
so
with this process one can
go through by the way a very important
section of all this it's the chain of
custody
all every move that we're trying to
predict
is helped by the fact that
the user
can check
the postal department or whoever
delivers the mail can check
on whether or not
the DNA
subject is there unit by unit
address party
by a dress party so
What's Happening Here is in in the case
of a DNA marked object and there are
many companies doing this now I have
some materials to show what's going on
in Europe and other places where it is
accepted in crime labs are all adjusted
to reading it the um
DNA test for covet is a DNA test it's
the same test
there are now millions of places where
this can be done so that there are
millions of products being marked this
these days and now
the absentee ballot by me having walked
through and enjoyed seeing how Enfield
does it
they do it well
but all the steps that you've put into
the I'm supporting this bill
not in its totality uh but because it
faces very up to the very big risks that
happen can happen have happened and
might be provably so by someone who
wanted to stop the process but so what's
going on here is you're absolutely
putting everyone's eyes into the
inspection knowing
that they will be known to have had it
everyone handling this from the design
of the printed object
to the pinning of it to the packaging of
it to sending it to wherever it's going
to go
recognizes the symbol that says DNA
marked
they therefore
become
individual supporters
of the process all the way through to
the end when it comes back to to the
office for testing so
um for or for logging in when it's
logged in
so it's a
it's a kind of a change in the world of
authentication and anti-counterfeiting
to trust
you can imagine if everyone's involved
in this process knows
that he has it she has it
she's moving on to where
every time maybe you're already familiar
with the fact that every time you take a
picture with your smartphone
it records the time date to the second
and the location by latitude and
longitude
that information and it shows then a
picture of that
here here's a example I've moved this
process myself into
my eye doctors Prescription Pad
so this prescription fat as
16 things on the back that make it
secure
is there any Security in reality
no
anyone could steal one of those sign it
the only security then is his signature
which is no longer considered valid
security and so this doctor who will
help tell this story
is very proud
to do that for himself
starting the chain of custody to that to
go on through so I have done uh this
on
enfields
ballots
personally for my own edification and as
mentioned to David I've been presenting
those results too
Secretary of State these are actual
ballots that you can print off of the
internet if you know you can go and get
the ballot I uh
mark them with a little red mark
which might have been done
by the but it doesn't matter uh by The
Operators the clerks
might have been done might have been
done by the printer before he started
and then
um
I watched I see how the people have to
put together this little complicated
package of items into the two different
envelopes and
uh first thing that happened for me by
the way without knowing it was my uh a
ballot came to my mailbox at 57 route 4A
and Enfield for someone else
I decided to press forward with this
project to get here today to tell you
you can get trust in that piece of paper
and you'll be able to know that if
someone copied it there's no DNA
transfer of course
if somebody
um
took it to a different place
and sent it back from a different place
it'll be identified so
it's a simple process I have some
examples of this going on in in Europe
in particular right now where they've
changed the way they handle cash
management to fill up ATM machines
present method if someone breaks that
open
they're sprayed with
blue fluorescent dye they're now sprayed
with blue fluorescent dye and DNA
the fact is in general people using our
systems of DNA or antibodies are
not bothering to test anymore
that's not an example but the fact is
it's a trustworthy process I will leave
in my testimony references to those
details
thank you questions from the committee
all right thank you very much thank you
on the blue sheet we have one in favor
for against
that closures of public hearing on House
Bill 482.
today
all right the executive sessions will
begin at
11 55 and we'll see how many we can roll
through in 20 minutes or a half hour
foreign
all right
we're gonna get going
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill three two four representative
Barry is recognized for a motion
uh yes Mr chairman I move that house
bill 324 be an expedient to legislate is
there a second
who was it uh Mr boam representative
bone
very bone Berry bomb which sounds like
breakfast as I say that sounds like a
that sounds like a marketing tool
all right would you like to speak to
your motion uh just briefly
um uh this bill creates a voter dollar
system uh in his taxpayer-funded
elections
um historically I've been opposed the
taxpayer funded elections I don't want
my tax dollars going to candidates I
don't like I'm sure um some of my
constituents prefer their tax dollars
not go to some some that they like and
ultimately it won't solve the problem
that it seeks to address which is it is
seeking to address the problem of
keeping money and influence away from uh
candidates um the reality is is the
money we you'd have a taxpayer system
and you'd have people who didn't use it
um the donors could then go form a Pao
which we'll discuss later
um or a pack that money will still be
used to do exactly what they wanted to
do anyways and in the meantime we will
have cost the New Hampshire taxpayers
upwards of six million dollars so that's
why I will be voting for an expedient to
legislate
further discussion
representative boom yeah thank you also
it doesn't do away with out of state
spending and then
what do we add State Senate races and
look at the state senate races they're
cut they're people that contribute to
them and when I ran for the state senate
I got most of my money from one donor in
California but the problem yeah it's
it's not going to stop and it would just
keep expanding it and it's not going to
stop packs independent packs from
campaigning out of state packs or
country or or other agencies from just
spending money I mean they don't have to
say they can I mean they don't have to
contribute to the candidate they just
have to say Vote for This candidate so
it's not going to really change anything
thank you
for the discussion
representative Muirhead
um I really thought that I had
representative Barry with my
um extraordinary arguments this morning
and I'm rather shocked that I didn't
persuade him but I did just want to note
uh very briefly that though it wouldn't
stop money I do think it would improve
the situation by create an Avenue for
candidates ordinary citizen candidates
with a lot of local support and I'm not
going to expand on that because
apparently I've already failed to uh to
persuade my erstwhile colleagues but I
did just want to know that let the
committee know that I am not giving up
thank you thank you for being a good
sport representative Lane
um I just wanted to highlight that um
one bill is not going to solve all the
money the dark money problems bill has
to be taken as part of that step so I
wouldn't expect one bill to solve all
the issues and
and to speak to representative mom's
point there are other bills that we need
to enact
to solve that problem and one of them
would be HB 195. so that's all
nice slip in at the end
I don't even have a chance to grab the
gobble
further discussion
okay the motion is an expedient to
legislate the clerk will call the roll
please
uh representative Berry yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative qualey yes
representative inkerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yeah
representative wary
representative wood yes
representative lean
no
representative Ward
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative murhead
representative Bay
no
representative Brennan no
representative Grill I vote no
representative Howard no
representative Palmer no
representative Smith
yes
and that is
10 to 10.
send the motion fails representative
Muirhead would you like to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I I'd like to uh move
that this um
that this uh move this be passed
is there a second
I'll second it
and since we know how this one ends the
clerk will call the roll
perfect uh representative Barry no
representative prudhom O'Brien no
representative boam
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg nope
representative Burnham no
representative Kennedy no
representative weary
representative wood
representative Lane yes
representative Ward
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative murhead
representative Bay
yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl votes yes
representative Howard yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Smith
no
another 10 to 10.
that motion fails this bill will go on
the house calendar with no
recommendation and I will need a
committee report the verbiage should be
supporters of an expedient to
legislative and supporters of ought to
pass
OTP at 10 10.
I don't know I'll get it later
so who will Who will do those committee
reports
Barry and Mir head and I will need them
today
appreciate that
and uh and so this these all committee
reports I don't know if I mentioned it
before I get reviewed by both the house
Clerk and the speaker
so
the way we can get into trouble is by
stating beliefs as facts so if it isn't
an explicit fact the correct language is
supporters of ought to pass believe that
and this way the reports are factually
correct
so no on the consent calendar no
nope and that closes the executive
session on House Bill 324.
okay I'm gonna set a record with this
one
open the executive session on House Bill
453 and recess the executive session on
House Bill 453 to February 14th
we're gonna do 508 next
what's up
all right
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 508 and representative wary
is recognized for a motion
I'd like to make a motion that be 508
would be in expedient to legislate
please is there a second
Larry boom
wary
exactly
would you like to speak to emotion
yes uh just briefly I think it
it uh
proposes a solution to a
problem that might be handled better in
other ways I
the
expenditure of a hundred thousand
dollars
growing in time
for absentee ballots doesn't seem to
be the I think the appropriate mechanism
to handle
uh challenges to get those absentee
balances
further discussion on the bill
was that
representative boom
thank you uh also too
um we just recessed 453 which will
cost what the cost is going to be uh on
payment of uh absentee balance so I
think this is premature for right now so
yeah we should it element and it puts
the money for the state paying it and
remember though also
what do we also pay for the gas going to
the polling place so I mean it's one or
the other you either pay postage or you
pay for your gas
so I support the itm
for the discussion representative Howard
yes uh HP 508 addresses an issue of a
poll tax essentially uh postage should
be paid for by the state because it is a
barrier even if it is a small one
you know when we're talking about paying
for gas uh that is an issue where we
could address that in a separate bill
but this tackles a very specific issue
uh and it's just supposed to remove any
barrier uh that may stand in the way of
somebody voting
representative Barry Oh yes I'll be
voting uh for the motion of index being
to legislate the notion that paying
postage on your absentee ballot is a
poll tax is uh
ridiculous
um there is always a cost to vote in
some way should we give them a pin
um to fill out their ballot when they
when we send them the absentee ballot
voting unfortunately has a cost driving
to the polls has a cost not outside of
the gasoline your time has a cost
everything has a cost we don't need to
create two classes of Voters by saying
we will completely Finance you if you
pull an absentee ballot but if you
decide to drive to the polls nope you
get to burn the entire cost we don't do
that here I will be voting in expedient
to legislate
further discussion on the bill
okay then
the motion is an expedient to legislate
the clerk will call the roll
representative Barry yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
that's a yes representative Baum yeah
representative quaali yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy yes
representative weary
representative wood yes
representative Lane no
representative worth
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet no
representative Moorhead
representative Bay no
representative Brennan no
representative girl votes no
representative Howard no
and uh representative Palmer no and
representative Smith yes
that is 10 to 10. and the motion fails
nope no no no I don't think so what
Heidi oh hi hi oh oh okay
that is eleven to nine
oh
yeah
yeah 11 and 9. sorry about that 11 and
five nine in favor the motion is adopted
closes the executive session on House
Bill 508.
yep uh so representative wary
[Music]
thinking this okay
so I need a majority report will there
be a Minority Report yes
no for the consent colleges
what's up okay
no
yeah
it's a physical note
three on one side I might ask
who's really better I love your opposite
yep you never know you never know
you ask it with such like technology
well the one time I don't it'll be
something of a consecutor
it is
a higher level functions
so we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 195 which is now recessed to
a time to be determined and closing uh
no we're going to recess not just say
close before you drop the hammer you're
kind of done yeah
alrighty
not too shabby you'll have a half hour
anyway
going straight to 196.
okay
[Music]
open the executive session on House Bill
196 representative Lane is recognized
for a motion
I'd like to put in a motion ought to
pass
a second
here in a minute I have an amendment oh
I'm sorry I apologize it's been a while
for me too yeah but you have to open
isn't that isn't that correct do they do
it wrong no you didn't we just need a
second okay
I got it
representative uh Ward give me a chance
oh sorry
thank you
good
is that adoption commendment so you got
the motion and you got the second
you know it's Hillary paws
okay representative Blaine's recognized
for further motion
um
I'd like to move
adopt uh the amendment
2023-0106h representative land moves
Amendment
two zero two three zero one zero six H
second
yeah now would you like to speak to that
motion representative Wayne uh yes
please
um
as as uh I testified I think last week
uh the amendment would change this from
a commission to a committee
um and I put the bill in uh to and it
changes who's appointed to it
um it's not as many people there's six
folks from the house and two from the
senate senate
um the idea is to do study of campaign
Finance which came out of the
recommendation of the Secretary of
State's
uh committee special committee on voter
protection so this would look just at
the campaign Finance sections of the in
of the uh election law not all of the
election law
so and it's my understanding that
Secretary of State testified that they
were in support of this bill
further discussion on the amendment
representative Berry is are we
supporting the amendment I do have
issues with the underlying bill
um however an interest of courtesy to
the other members I believe that if
there's limits operating in good faith
even if you have issues with the
underlying bill it's prudent to support
them
further discussion
okay the motion is whether to adopt
Amendment 20230106h
representative Barry yes
representative predom O'Brien yes
representative boam yes
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward
was that yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative mayorhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grove votes yes
representative Howard
yes
representative Palmer yes
and representative Smith yes
that is twenty to zero excuse me and the
amendment I was skipped oh oh I'm so
sorry that's okay representative Burnham
yes okay
now it's 20 to zero all right and the
amendment's still adopted so that's nice
so no the Parliamentary situation is the
beginning of the amendment says amend
the bill by replacing all after the
enacting Clause with the following that
means this amendment is now the bill
so uh is there discussion on the bill
representative Barry
um I'll be opposing this um I do believe
that the sponsor is acting in incredibly
good faith
um I just question it's necessity given
that when reviewing it
um it appears that it's basically the
functions of this committee right so
like this committee is supposed to
review election law it falls underneath
our purview I'd much rather see us just
form a subcommittee
um and just work on it as a committee
than to enact RSA incur all the costs
that go with that
um there's nothing wrong with in my
opinion there's nothing wrong with the
actual bill itself as amended
um even before amended I just don't
believe it's necessary and I will say if
this committee wanted to form a
subcommittee and review this I'd happy
to be on it and be a part of it
um I'm not opposed to what this is
trying to to do I'm just opposed to how
it's trying to do it because I believe
that is our job on this committee to do
what this bill does
further discussion
okay
the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment two zero
two three zero one zero six h
uh
you can call the world
no because we um we had the motion about
to pass with a second
and then we had the motion to adopt the
amendment with a second and that's where
we're at now
representative Barry no
representative prudomo Brian no
representative Baum well
Representative qualey no
representative Ankerberg
nope
representative Brenham no
representative Kennedy
representative weary
representative wood no
representative Lane yes
representative Ward
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative murhead
representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative girl votes yes
representative Howard yes representative
Palmer yes and representative Smith
no
that is 10 to 10.
and the motion fails
representative Berry is recognized for a
motion uh yes Mr chairman I move that
house bill 196 as amended be in
expedient to legislate
representative yes
very cool
sounds like an upscale
it's fowl yeah
you were not the first person to make a
food joke about my last name it will not
be the last
representative Berry
um I vote Yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yes
representative qualey yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary yes
representative wood yes
representative Wayne no
representative Ward no
representative Hamer no
representative Hamlet no
representative Moorhead
representative Bay no
representative Brennan no
representative grow votes no
representative Howard no
representative Palmer no
and representative Smith
yes
and that is another 10 to 10
. The Spill Will Go On The House
calendar with no recommendation the two
reports will be supporters of ought to
pass as amended
and supporters of inexperience to
legislate who will do those
okay
yes
all right all right and that closes the
executive session on House Bill 196.
see you at one
that looks good they saved you like 20
minutes to the line and everything
I get to get over to a Committee hearing
and
Finance
um
yep I apologize
thought I had a I thought a uh
representative Smith was gonna cover for
me or whatever
um all right so we will open uh up the
public hearing on House Bill 599
relative to requiring an audit of the
November 2022 elections
is there a
is the sponsor here
am I missing one yeah
there's another one
oh there's a bunch
welcome
thank you representative acting chairman
Barry
um my name is representative Sandra
panick
um
thank you for allowing me to speak on
House Bill 599
the citizens of New Hampshire are I'm
not going to say demanding I want to use
the word pressing
for a forensic audit of the election
process to determine the overall health
of the you know of the New Hampshire
election process
this request sits on the lower voters
confidence on record
you will hear testimony today on the
findings of citizens audit efforts and
personal experiences that support this
Rising concern
and give it validity to the need for
this audit
this is also our opportunity to back up
the work
from the 2022 vote of confidence
committee who heard testimony but were
unable to substantiate the claims of
those who participated
it is up to us
the legislators to hear the voices of
the people
New Hampshire has never had a thorough
audit of our election process we are
long overdue
the purpose of House Bill 599 is to use
samples of 15 towns with targeted races
Senate Congress and governor
as a test case and audit it with
impartial never before used third party
who can provide an evaluation of the New
Hampshire election process and tools
should there be a larger than a two
percent Gap
a larger sample would be taken to assess
the scope of the process issues
the effort will be absent of personal
personal
participation of stakeholders like
audits conducted by CPA firms
for publicly traded companies this is
not only is a best practice but it
removes any potential concerns for the
bias in the audit
the audit will be visible to the public
where bipartisan participation in the
volunteerism
the audit team will doc will document
and identify the process gaps detail
areas of vulnerability
and Report inconsistencies and results
reported
they will make recommendations on their
findings to be acted upon by legislature
this effort will be used to improve
election practices and restore voter
confidence
we expect funding to come from a
combination of appropriations of a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars from
the state with additional funds as
donations from the public I respectfully
ask the committee to support this bill
and I'm not going to take any questions
again on this bill I am just the vessel
to deliver the bill and
um we have Brenda Town who will speak on
this if you have any questions thank you
very much for taking my taking your time
for me
thank you so I think uh we'll be prudent
rep next up would be uh Brenda town from
East
wait
Ace East Wakefield thank you
thank you everybody on the committee and
there's no well there's our assistant
chair I'm not sure
I think they call me Vice chair
sometimes all right Vice chair thank you
very much
um and I appreciate the second time up
to bat here today
um I'm here to talk to you about the
merits of Bill HB 599 which would
introduce the concept of doing an audit
on the process that we use for election
um as you guys know we are at one of the
lower points in voter confidence the
numbers reported from the voter
confidence committee indicated that
about 50 percent of the people who came
forward and testified were very
concerned and had concerns about the
performance of areas of the election
process and as we have never had an
audit in the state of New Hampshire it
is a best practice and would be done on
an annual basis if we were a company
so I I want to let you guys know that I
participated with a whole group of hard
work in New Hampshire citizens on a
citizen's audit we uh and again if you I
gave this a handy um handout for you I'm
just going to walk through this as I
talk so that it kind of backs up the
points
so I was a member of this citizens audit
we did an audit of the 2020 election and
we are in a motion on the midterm
election audit ourselves personally but
there are certainly limitations to what
we can and can't do uh the team uh did
over a thousand uh 91a requests we
raised a hundred thousand dollars in the
course of one week
we have 8 000 people who follow us on
Facebook and um Telegram
we have 400 active volunteers and we've
had some help from National expert
experts which was wonderful we spent
thousands and thousands of hours on data
collection and as you can imagine being
a non-indigenous legislative or election
official this was new ground for all of
us and then we followed it up with over
1200 hours of canvassing knocking on
doors and just trying to get some
feedback on the voter that cast the vote
um actually that was registered on the
day of the election are they the ones
that cast the vote did they vote and so
we did that work as well
um to start with there were some really
weird things that happened in 2020 that
um and I say weird because we don't have
the facts behind it we just have the
indicators and that's why we need the
audit
we saw and the page two you'll see the
voter Trends
um over time
and these are two counties in the state
of New Hampshire and you're going to see
that the state of New Hampshire over
that period of time grew four percent in
population
but as you look through the numbers and
I know there's a lot of numbers on here
you're going to see that the Republican
party in Rockingham County
uh grew by uh 7.3 percent in 2012 2.9
percent in 2016 and then a six percent
growth in 2020 but when you look at the
Democrat Party there were some really
interesting Trends there was a decline
of 4.3 and then a growth of 0.2 a
negative uh growth of of 0.2 and then
there was a 25 growth in Democrat votes
in 2020.
and so when you have a state that only
grew by four percent there's just some
dichotomy in the numbers we don't know
if this is right wrong or indifferent
but we have no way to get to what drove
those unusual things to happen and so
again just trying to get our arms around
what's happening in the state
I have on the next page one of the
things that we found in the citizens
audit machine performance and we did put
together a complete machine performance
um
and that's this page you guys we did put
together a complete machine performance
report
and what we did is we collected the
machine tapes from every town across New
Hampshire and we Pareto them by town so
that you could see how each machine
reported per candidate I did a sample
just to show you Merrimack on the
presidential and the government governor
race what you'll see is across the top
the overall distribution of Republicans
Independents and Democrats that lived in
Merrimack and then when you look at the
machines below you'll see that Merrimack
had nine machines
but there were three machines that
performed out of bounds to the overall
performance of not only the town
composition but the other machines we
don't know why that happened but we just
know that it's unusual and statistically
it's very very improbable
so again another flag that said hey
maybe we should check this out and have
this included as part of an audit
on the next slide it just again another
driver on a reason that we really would
like to see an audit
is that on the day that we publish our
voter turnout in 2020 we publish to the
nation that New Hampshire had
experienced a 72.2 percent voter turnout
in the 2020 election that was pretty
outstanding we were third in the nation
with those results
but less than
um 10 months later 11 months later we
did the 10-year Purge of our voter
registration and we removed 230
000 voters from the New Hampshire voter
rolls
when we recast the numbers of what the
actual voter turnout for the active
voters would have been in the 2020
election New Hampshire would have
experienced a 92.5 percent voter turnout
with the recast cleaned up registration
that is a statistical anomaly and if you
can see that we would have jumped to the
number one position and exceeded it by
nearly 20 points so something is just
not right
and finally just to touch a little bit
on our canvas
when we canvassed we actually found that
there were over 9 000 people on our
voter that voted in the 2020 election
who had submitted requests for permanent
move of address from their uh the
address that they voted from again we
don't know if those folks are are com
currently domiciled in New Hampshire
whether they um
they decided to stay at that address
after they formally changed their
address but we do know that it's
unlikely that all nine thousand of those
folks still reside in New Hampshire and
had a vote cast in their names
for the midterms we use the same
strategy we use the active voter
registration
and we bounced it against
um the USPS permanent move database of
people who had moved over the prior two
years and what we found is that there
were 64 000 people who remained on the
New Hampshire voter registration who had
moved out of County or out of state and
they had not been removed
so these are some of the leading
indicators that lead us to believe that
we've got some gaps in the way that we
do our elections
and we're really anxious to actually
take an opportunity to dive deep into
our elections do this audit with an
impartial third party and then take the
results and learn from them
I mean we can't correct what we don't
know and if you've ever been a party of
somebody who's been in Alcoholics
Anonymous that's truly their their motto
you can't fix what you don't acknowledge
and we need to get to the bottom of how
things are going to build up voter
confidence and to improve our our
process here
and just on another note
um again my role in in Corporate America
I again did a lot of business controls
and it was a standard practice that we
would audit our business every single
year using a third party you are not
allowed to trade on the New York Stock
Exchange if you did not have a
foundational audit to confirm that your
results were accurate because people are
investing their hard-earned money into
the the health of that company
and so we are asking the people of New
Hampshire to invest and believe into our
election process and we owe them an
audit so thank you very much and I'd be
glad to answer any questions around the
the terms of of the bill itself
questions from the committee
representative wood
thank you Mr chair uh and thank you for
taking my question uh looking at the
data here that you provide most of it is
manipulation long word uh recalculation
of data that you found
in the 1200 hours door knocking
what type of feedback did you get from
actually actual people what type of
things concerned you from that as far as
so we're not talking about you
surprising that a 92 percent number is
too big
actual fact sure so we we canvassed
Waterville in Rye and
um roughly 13 of the people that we
queried had either not voted in the
election or it was the prior owner that
lived at that home or they said that
they voted in person but they were
logged as an absentee ballot or we did
have an instance where an address didn't
exist we had found like the lease office
in Waterville had a vote cast from it so
we had those kind of issues found
that's what drove the focus in our
online canvas work because the repeat
issue that we found is when we knocked
on doors and we spoke to the voter we
would have two last names and so we'd
say Hey you know we've got Bob Smith
voted from this house in yard George
Jones
um did Bob vote does Bob live here and
they said oh no I bought the house from
him you know two years ago
and so we had this situation that led us
to believe that we had a gap in our
process that prior owners or people that
were moving might still be voting and I
know in New Hampshire there's a tad of a
gray area of is that your domicile or
not but the but the uh volume that we
found and we just left the Attorney
General's office and although we
provided this information to the
confidence committee we left them we've
we've got about 900 but I left him with
about 700 cases where we documented the
home was sold from one family to another
family
months or a couple years before the
election in both parties both families
voted in the election so there is a gap
that's been created in the process
there's a check follow-up follow-up
um so 700
that can't be the 1200 that you're not
or that might have must have been
another survey you did yes but let me go
back to what you said you found some
anomaly so out of the 1200 how many
anomalies do you have a number yeah we
found approximately 80 that 80 80 uh of
the doors that were opened so it kind of
goes like this you knock on 600 doors
and maybe 500 or 400 answer and then you
end up with people that can give you
some direction on their voting that
leads you to know that there's a problem
okay so the 80 is not really out of 1200
because I swallowed it so the 1200 are
the hours that we saw so it takes a lot
of time a feed on the street so we did
do two towns with a team of canvassers
and um that's what led us to the further
work
one more question
um Mr chair if you don't mind follow-up
sorry uh I read that wrong sorry so what
I guess the word I was looking at
percentage what percentage of anomalies
did you find when the people answered
and went through all right it was
roughly 13 of the people who answered
yeah thank you sorry representative Bay
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um on the bill uh there's a reference to
uh technical lead who's being hired uh
can you speak to the background of that
technical lead in terms of uh
qualification and experience
so um from my my narrow com uh direction
of what a technical lead would be it
would be somebody who has enough
knowledge of the election process enough
knowledge of how to
um be able to separate roles
responsibilities to make sure there's no
conflict and kind of like a CPA but
there would also be a technical
component for somebody who understands
you know I.T related issues so that they
could understand if there's a
vulnerability in our voting machines
follow-up follow-up
so um for that person would you make it
a necessary qualification that this
person has worked in an election
I or disqualification
well I you know obviously they would
have to have a some election history to
be able to understand the voting
machines and how elections work
um and I again I think we leave the
definition of the who the right
technical expert would be to the the
people that have to hire that person
um because I want them to be able to
weigh in since they've got to manage
this process and they have to have
somebody who can guide them
and so for me if I were on the committee
I'd want somebody I could ask good
questions to who could guide us on how
we were commencing the audit process
thank you okay
further questions from the committee
representative Howard
thank you Mr chair uh and thank you for
coming today I I want to ask about the
sum of 150 000 uh and how that number
was uh
kind of decided
well we we determined that hiring
somebody to be able to conduct the audit
a professional that we would be paying a
chunk of that for that professional and
then beyond that it was just a budgetary
number and as I included in my
um overview we were successful at being
able to do fundraising from the citizens
of New Hampshire because they're
passionate about this issue and if we're
asking you to do something I think it's
it's really good that we would put our
money where our mouth was and
participate so we thought that that
funding from the state with fundraising
from the population would be a great way
to partner and have this work done
further questions from the committee
representative um representative where
do you have a question
representative will come back to you
because you've already asked we're going
to representative Weir first
yes thank you
Mr chair and um
Miss Town
um
on the Merrimack uh slide does that are
different Awards represented there or do
you know if the machines came from
different areas or sections of the town
I believe there's two machines in each
location and that they are representing
different locations within Merrimack I'm
that's my understanding
but there was no one of the things that
I wanted to be clear is if you look at
that slide
um we when we did do our reporting and
it is available for every town so it's a
pretty fascinating report and I'll be
glad to get it to the committee but
you'll see that we did across the top is
a breakdown of uh that the party
affiliation of the mail-in ballots by
Democrat versus Republican versus
independent is the same as the people
who voted in person
and none of these machines were specific
to an in-person or an absentee ballot
processing they the ballots for both
parties were processed on both machines
at the locations or across all these
machines they weren't isolated like they
didn't put all absentees through machine
three six and nine so again just a it
was a flag to us as we were doing our
audit and it's just worthy of following
up and as I'll get that the full report
out to the committee but you'll see that
this isn't an isolated thing in
Merrimack that you'll find that across
the state we have machines that are
performing outside the bounds of the
overall affiliation of the parties
within the towns
follow up uh follow-up yeah so you state
that that's statistically improbable do
you have a estimate of I mean it what is
the odds that three machines would be so
highly selective toward one candidate
versus the averages that seem to appear
in the other machines well the the best
way I can answer is there is a a
documentary called hacking democracy and
they ran this analysis down in Georgia
when there was a suspicion that one of
the democratic candidates had been lost
a race because of machine manipulation
and they conducted this same exercise
and they said that this type of result
is one in a million that this would not
statistically happen so I'm not a
statistician but I can tell you that
that is that that particular guidance
when we did this machine tape analysis
was something that we took to heart and
that's why I wanted to demonstrate we
did have machines performing out of
bounds to what you would expect and I
just think even if you're not a
statistician and you look at the way
that the distribution of voter history
is and how people are registered and
then you look at how the machines are
performed it does raise just a normal
person's questions of how could that
happen
thank you
representative Bay
thank you Mr chairman
um on the
um third party audit company can you
enlighten me on that I'm not familiar uh
with this so what type of company is
this is this something that's in state
out of state what's in their resume have
they done it uh in other states or do
you have a specific company in mind I I
have no company in mind
um I in my background I would normally
recommend that you would use like a CPA
firm with a technical lead who has an
experience in the technology and
elections and used them in concert one's
going to be very methodical and
evaluating uh process you know how is
the process working yeah are there
issues have we not been following the
process is there an exposure that's kind
of the brain of a CPA type of firm and
then the technologist who gives us kind
of the view of how the machines perform
and where the vulnerabilities they could
kind of weigh into are there exposures
there and are there things that we as a
date should be doing differently to
protect the vote
follow-up
so there is no uh type of company in
existence in the United States that
specifically does election audits I mean
there have been
um teams that have done audits in other
states
but I didn't want to be prescriptive I
wanted New Hampshire to be able to find
that right partner we're using
um we're using machines that are you
know a couple decades old
um in our process is very dispersed
across towns as opposed to centralized
so I think that we're a bit of a unique
situation so we should be able to
customize the audit approach that makes
the most sense for the way that we do
our elections
okay
are there questions from the committee
saying none thank you thank you very
much I really appreciate your time next
up is Deb Rory
how do you um what what town are you
from
you from Manchester I think there's a
couple of us here from Manchester
thank you Vice chair and committee for
letting me speak on this bill I just
wanted to say that I'm in favor of this
bill because I believe it would be
instrumental in improving voter
confidence
um within the citizens of the state
although we're not technically a
business we do pay taxes and all of us
have an interest in how and where our
money is spent and our elections are
very valuable to each one of us and
where there are holes in the system like
I spoke to earlier about the absentee
ballot reconciliation
um lack of that process
I believe that having this type of an
audit would um
would improve our confidence and would
allow us to just see where improvements
need to be made like Brenda mentioned
that businesses do collect do conduct
Audits and although we're not like
technically a business and each town is
responsible for their own elections
um
we do need to make sure that things are
running smoothly and the only way that I
can think of to do it is to
um
ask for your support of this bill and
give We the People the opportunity to
just see where um there are things that
need to be improved and if everything
comes out fine then great but from what
I've observed personally there are areas
for improvement and not to say again
that anyone's doing anything wrong but
it's just you know a bipartisan way of
increasing our confidence because we'll
be able to see an actual report of you
know investigations and people looking
into processes that do have
um you know some holes to them so I just
wanted to make that statement excellent
you don't have to take questions if you
don't want to you can are there
questions from the committee
see look it solved itself thank you so
much next up uh
al-randano did I get that right Mr
Brandon I think um and you are from
Kingston New Hampshire Kensington
Kensington
oh yeah absolutely bring it up to if you
want to give it to the clerk
sorry I'm holding that from you for no
reason
thank you Vice chairman and to the
committee
my name is Al brendano I'm from
Kensington New Hampshire
um I have been
um really kind of honored to be part of
a volunteer group of uh to work with
Brenda and Deb and a whole bunch of
other people through the voter
conference committee and working with
the secretary of state and his assistant
it's been a rewarding experience
but I'd like to start out I rise in
support of the house bill 599
first why am I here
the New Hampshire Constitution Article 8
instructs the citizens
of the accountability of its magistrates
and offices
Public's right to know article 38 is
social virtues and in calculated the
right of the citizens to require their
law gives and magistrates and exact and
constant observers observance of them
and the formation and execution of laws
why am I in support of HB 599
because I believe sadly that this
committee uh did not get the consent of
the people
uh in their constitutional duties
and I'll point to two specific uh points
one is
almost 30 years ago codified an RSA
65640 uh you approved on a trial basis
voting machines
those were never constitutionally
adopted
secondly we have an increase in really
repugnant and
expansion of absentee ballots that once
again Falls outside your purview and
should have gone to the consent of the
voters
many of us today who testify before your
committee
worked with the voter confidence group
our experience and transparency and
fairness many of us spent thousands of
hours of personal time and money to be
part of a solution
what what may not be transparent to your
committee
after review of that document was that
the public testimony and evidence that
was produced was not given out you may
have not seen it in the voter confidence
uh committee report I'll ask you to look
at that because a lot of us produced
evidence and that committee's position
was that we're not accepting evidence
we're just looking at confidence but if
you dig deeper in there you'll find it
one service the second one is the
service of a remonstrance and letter of
trespass this is very important we serve
the Secretary of State the Department of
Justice for the unconstitutional use of
machines on March 1st 2022 and we're
still awaiting an official response
third
a statement of blind trust if you look
at the report number l
that machines were used correctly and
more accurate than hand count lacks any
empirical data peer review or basis of
fact to Stage such claims
if they're going to State a claim in
that report they really should stand
behind it
nearly 30 percent of towns in New
Hampshire hand count exclusively as well
as a host of industrialized countries in
Europe
four it lacks strong clear and essential
voting policy and procedure changes
supported by evidence presented as well
as critical components that would help
prevent future unlawful Acts or
impossible misconduct
five
it leaned strongly into protecting
election election officials
but failed to ever mention protecting
the Civil Rights and sovereignty of the
citizen voter
Town clerks and moderators all have
legal protection and representation
through their associations
paid for by our tax dollars
to the contrary
if a citizen voter has no other option
than to file a legal challenge in
Superior Court at his expense or her
expense
that's unexpected that's really
unacceptable
sixth the last official security update
for the accuvelt machine is April 10th
2010.
that's from the Secretary of State's
office imagine your Microsoft computer
not having an update since April 10th
April 10 2010.
included in that April 10 2010
directive
they were directed to cut modems the
wires of the modem inside the machine
because the machine was communicating
outside at its time to a plug-in modem
when they when they cut the modem wires
as a result of a security update they
made the machines lose their UL
certification making them a possible
health and fire hazard as reported to
OSHA on September 12 2022 by an expert
witness Wayne P Sayer and all this
everything I'm telling you is backed up
in the information that I gave you
seventh the accuvote machine maintenance
in towns is accomplished with no record
of serial number replacement parts or
confirmation that Hardware like
motherboards or microchip programming
has any chain of custody you'll see in
the documents 91a requests from the
Department of Justice and the Secretary
of State's office there is no chain of
custody we don't know when somebody does
maintenance on the machine if those
parts even meet any certification
because there's no serial numbers on any
of those parts
and last in the 2020 recount
uh just recently in District 24 we
worked a bunch of us work that and
expose an inexcusable listing of ballot
chain of custody and witness and box
failures which may I say may have
affected an election that's still under
review
torn boxes need to be replaced with
tamper-proof bins
citizens in New Hampshire constitutional
expert Dan Richard is also challenging
the legitimacy and constitutionality of
the expansion of the absentee ballot
process
I hope you'll support that process in
summary
we're at a Crossroads of a growing us
against them sediment that can't be
whitewashed
members of this committee I ask you will
you lead and act on the evidence and
recommendations of the voter confidence
committee
will you lead with the mindset to
placing a value of our votes as we do
our personal money
will you lead with utilizing the best
voting practices in banking style Audits
and procedures
the Secretary of State's website claims
New Hampshire is the easiest place for
voters to register and cast their votes
but do we not make us why do we not make
a statement it's the securist also
then the people of New Hampshire will be
best served and your leadership will
help restore our constitutional and
civic duty pride and public comment
commitment to government then and only
then when you get the people's consent
will you be worthy of a first in the
nation's status thank you
foreign questions please any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you next up
uh represent excuse me Ken earring from
Windham
I ring or hearing I'm sorry I'm drawing
a blank on how we pronounce your last
name
hi good afternoon it's Ken eyring thank
you for the time to testify
I do support HB 599
um I was honored to have served on
secretary Scanlon special Committee of
voter confidence
because election integrity and
confidence in our election and process
is important
and over the five or six months period
where we were listening to testimony I'd
say about half the people expressed
concerns about our elections
I'm from Windham and I have first-hand
experience regarding what can go wrong
when election officials don't follow
election laws and procedures the Windham
general election on November 2020
produce the largest numerical
discrepancy in the history of New
Hampshire
and over 130 violations of election laws
and procedures were identified by the AG
and the Secretary of State
that led to the appointment of an
election monitor for this past
primary election in September but even
with the election monitor there were
still issues
so I want to share just a few examples
that were included in a complaint that I
filed along with another Windham
resident with the AG's office I emailed
that to this committee earlier today
so I I encourage you to look at that
just to see the types of issues that
could come up and the lack of
um the lack of of following the proper
procedures as defined in the election
procedures manual and how they can
impact an election and the results
so here's a few examples
in New Hampshire one ballot promoter
means that at the end of the day when
the number of Voters that are announced
and the number of ballots that were cast
are calculated they should match
it's one to one
there are different methods that can be
used to independently confirm the number
of Voters and the number of ballots that
were cast
and when those totals are compared it
ensures accuracy when they do match
but for the Wyndham primary they did not
match in fact they were wildly off
enormously off
so the number of announced voters on
Election night was 3724.
that number was
959 higher than the actual number of
Voters that were marked as having voted
on the election day checklist that's
unacceptable it's unconscionable
the number of announced voters did not
match the number of cast ballots per the
chain of custody records the chain of
custody records show that there were 372
more ballots cast than voters on
Election night
again that's unacceptable that's an
enormous discrepancy especially one in
New Hampshire there's a history
of of an average of One race per
election that's decided by one or less
votes
and my third example out of our
complaint is the number of election day
ballots that were sealed in the ballot
boxes per the chain of custody records
was 100 was 1 333 more than the number
of election day ballots the town
received from the Secretary of State how
can that be
these are just a few examples that raise
alarms for me and many other people and
when I served on the committee of voter
confidence I was shocked that people I
did not even know came and testified and
referenced when Tim as one of their
reasons why they had an enormous lack of
confidence in the voting process here
none of those numbers that I just shared
with you were even close and none of
them matched and there are many many
other examples
I would suggest if you talk to your
Town's moderator or town clerk they
would tell you that
two or three maybe four disc ballots and
voter discrepancy is acceptable to put
anything over that is not
and in some of these cases they were
over a thousand
there were issues with uh official
election results as well and I just want
to touch upon a couple of these just
again to share with you how important it
is and how a lack of following election
long procedures
um is is important to look into and try
to identify where the issues are and
which is why I support the audit because
I think it will help
make all of our election officials
across the state be more diligent in
following the processes
so
um there were four different
return of votes filed for the Republican
primary and for return of votes for the
Democrat primary The Originals on
Election night just after election night
and three corrected versions
and one of those corrected Democrat
return of vote showed two candidates
received more votes than ballots cast
that's an impossible outcome that should
never even have been reported
looking at the Republican return of
votes the last two corrected and these
are official return of votes
they declared the wrong winner for this
District 17 State Rep race
a recount by the secretary of state
determined the correct winner and change
the result back so the correct person
and the elected person is serving now
but without that recount we would have
the wrong person serving now in the
State House
so those examples and many more in the
complaint that were filed with the AG
there's more issues for the November 22
general election and we're going to file
that as a as a separate complaint in the
upcoming weeks it takes a long time to
put these things together because I
provided links to all official documents
to make it easy for the AG to do their
investigation
that's a snapshot of Windham
but the issues are not isolated to wind
him
other towns have issues too which is why
I believe the audit is a good idea
for instance there were 188 uncounted
absentee ballots in bedford's November
2020 election and when they did an
investigation I think they found two
more
County and Merrimack and Nottingham also
had ballots that were not counted
laconia's 2020 ballots
that had right in votes had those votes
counted twice and the AG's office said
that might have affected the outcome of
some races but we'll never know
as a result of these known issues
monitors were pointed to Windham Laconia
and Bedford for the September 22 primary
election
but as you can see in the complaint that
I filed
the presence of an election monitor did
not prevent more wildly and accurate
Errors By our Windham election officials
that's why I support the audience the
audits
that would follow a business model so it
would follow the process from the
beginning to the end when the ballots
were printed when they were shipped when
they were received how many of them were
processed by voters how many were not
cast
all the way through from beginning to
end including
verifying that the computation of votes
at the end of the night was done
properly
going back to the paper tapes on the
machines making sure that they're added
up properly and that the vote totals in
the end reflect the will of the voters
so I appreciate your time and if you
have any questions I'll be happy to
answer them
questions from the committee
saying none thank you thank you very
much
uh I have no other pink cards except for
the Secretary of State's office
um so Secretary of State Scanlon
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State
and as I get started I would like to say
that I have worked uh with several
members that have just testified several
of the speakers have just testified
before your committee and you know I
believe that you know their
presentations are sincere they have
concerns their concerns are legitimate
um and you know we have been working
with them to try and alleviate those
um as I mentioned in earlier testimony
this morning
we have a system that has been developed
over a couple of centuries
uh it certainly isn't perfect
um there's always areas where we can
improve
um
and with your help I mean we we do that
I do not believe that this bill is the
way to go I think that conducting an
audit of several towns maybe broadening
that scope from the 2022 election is
um
is counterproductive
we know from the experience in Windham
when there was a audit conducted there
very similar to what's proposed here
that it took I believe it was three
weeks
it was
incredibly resource intensive it was
very expensive and it took a lot of time
to to get that job done
that was productive because it it
identified the problem that that caused
the issue in Windham and I won't get
into that now but I'm happy to talk
about it to anybody that's interested
I think
I think that doing an audit is proposed
in this bill is not going to tell us
anything that we don't already know and
that we're not already working on
and those things are being
more transparent
uh the elections are not meant to be
done behind closed doors or in secret
the only thing that should be secret
about elections is the voters ballot
that they've cast
there are many checks and balances that
are in place in a polling place
um but that doesn't mean that sometimes
things go wrong
because it's a human process mistakes
are made and mistakes need to lead to
anomalies and those show up on the
return of votes forms and information
that's reported
we do look at those when they jump out
at us and try and find answers for them
but the areas where we need to work to
instill more voter confidence I believe
doing things like post-election audits
and the policy has been that we're
testing systems out now in the 2022
general election
uh we did a number of things that
certainly helped uh
verify the results uh one was keeping
track of undervotes and overvotes when
ballots are being counted not only at
the local level but also during recounts
that was real really useful information
and I think it helped give confidence
the legislature required in the 22-22
primary a high-speed scanner audit of
Two Towns and then that was doubled in
the general election to four towns
and then in addition to that when we
conducted recounts of state
representative races we were required by
Statute to conduct a hand audit hand
count of uh
a office higher up on the ticket whether
it was a U.S Senate Governor or congress
and we did that and in those instances
the the results of those audits verified
the results of the election in those
communities that we tested but we should
do it on a broader scale and I've been
approached by
uh some very well-known uh election
uh
technology experts at both Andrew Apel
and Mark Linderman both names that you
may recognize but they're very
interested in helping New Hampshire set
up some type of a post-election audit
system that is statistically meaningful
and would verify the results I think
would be better off spending our money
and resources going in that direction at
this point than looking back
um
additional poll worker training I mean
that is an ongoing thing and and in the
last year we've dramatically increased
the scope and the types of trainings
that we put on we need to do more there
our local election officials are not
required to attend trading sessions uh
they do it if they can and but we do see
a difference those officials that tend
to go to training usually have fewer
problems than those that don't
so that's an area that we should keep
working on
and then we're looking at additional
technology in the polling place we are
looking to replace the the optical scan
accuvote ballot counting machines which
are currently being used and aging to
the point where you know their useful
life is in the foreseeable future
we are currently testing for
digital scan about accounting devices we
tested a model during the general
election opens with open source software
called voting works we are going to be
testing three different models for the
upcoming town elections the Dominion
device in Londonderry and Milford
the E and the es and S device in
Winchester
and the clear ballot device in Ashland
so if you live near any one of those
towns and you want to see how they're
working you know show up at their
polling place on town meeting day
and then we need to encourage the
expanded use of e-poll books right now
there are 16 communities in New
Hampshire that are using electronic poll
books
to check in voters and Report the
information after the election that
represents about 150 000 registered
voters in New Hampshire
that is going to be a really useful tool
moving forward and I think money would
be better spent developing that process
as well so I will in there Mr chairman I
would be happy to answer any questions I
don't think you'll be able to get away
with no questions
um representative boam
en thank you for taking the question
on a three machines in Merrimack 2020
that had the anomaly
could you maybe somehow explain that
I I don't have an explanation other than
to say that there can be conditions in
the polling place that might cause that
and one of the more common ones in the
2020 election with a pandemic we had
three times more absentee ballots than
normal and those tended to be
by far Democratic ballots and so if if
the local election officials were using
a particular ballot accounting device to
process absentee ballots that would show
what might be considered an anomaly
there may be other reasons that uh you
would have to look at the conditions on
the polling place to make that
determination
follow-up
did you see any such anomaly in the 2022
election
to be honest with you I didn't look at
that especially in Merrimack
representative weary
thank you Vice chair and uh thank you
secretary
um
so there's a lot of changes going on and
you stated that you don't want to look
back would you be in favor of a full
skip I I assume that the
audit looking backwards is to determine
how widespread some of the errors that
were found in a place like Windham are
in other communities within New
Hampshire you're proposing that we not
look back would you be alternatively in
favor of a full forensic audit after the
next election after some of these
changes have been implemented
I I think there should be a reason for
it in Windham we had a reason to look
back because there was a huge
discrepancy that just could not be
explained and it was explained
uh certainly at least to our
satisfaction after that audit was done
but right now there is no reason
there's no there's no huge gaping
concern that you know somebody's holding
an office that shouldn't be there
especially at a higher level
there's no reason to look back and I
think that certainly from my perspective
and I think from other election
officials
perspective that
if we're going back just to see what's
you know what can be improved in the
election process I think we already know
the answer to that and I think we're
already working on those Solutions and I
think by developing them
we are going to build confidence
and uh
and the numbers are going to be tighter
um and and I think that's that's
progress I think that's the direction
that we should head in I know that the
Windham audit was hundreds of thousands
of dollars
um that's just one town
and if we you know if we multiply that
by five you know we're in the millions
of dollars and if we expand that to
large counties because we're you know
some places outside that two percent
we're going to blow the state budget we
just don't have those kind of resources
and the money that we do have I think
should be would be better placed working
on the initiatives that we have that I
think are going to have meaning
meaningful results uh for everybody
that's involved in elections
uh before we do a follow-up with any
other questions from the committee okay
we'll do a follow-up
so it's it would seem though I mean just
trying to understand the the perceived
lack of voter confidence is that there
it seems like people are concerned that
they don't know what they don't know and
there's a lot of
this seems to be a very black box
of approach to things you're not uh
fully able to see or the the average
citizen is not able able to fully see
into that election process how
what would you propose to kind of
alleviate that
um perception and this lack of voter
confidence that has been expressed
you've had on an excellent point because
where where the concern is and where the
doubt comes in and the lack of
confidence
occurs primarily in those areas of the
process where the person can't actually
see what's going on and a voting machine
is a perfect example of that
um absentee voting you know the absentee
ballot leaves the possession of the Town
Clerk and you know there's all kinds of
theories about what happens to that
ballot before it gets back to the clerk
those are the areas you know if you
listen closely enough
where there are concerns that so somehow
we have to be able to
open that process up so that
you know the people are looking at it
can have the confidence so one way of
doing that is in terms of ballot
counting machines use accounting device
that uses open source software not
proprietary software that's protected
and kept secret by the company that
makes the machine but it's software that
anybody that has the technical knowledge
to look at can look at it and see how
it's counting the ballots and you know
that's one way to do it and another way
to do it post-election audits the
digital scan technology today and ballot
counting devices has the ability to
record the image of every single ballot
that gets fed through the machine and
based on that you can randomly select
ballots see how the machine counted it
compare it to the actual paper ballot
that was cast through the machine that
type of thing helps build confidence
um and so I think those are the you know
those are the areas that we should be
looking it's as I said earlier the only
part of the voting process that should
be private is how that voter voted on
their particular ballot and that's
further questions
uh representative Hamlet
after chair and vice chair and thank you
Mr Secretary of State
um so after the November 2022 general
election there were a lot of recounts
and I participated I helped with a
couple of those recounts yeah thank you
for that you're welcome and so were
there any large discrepancies in those
in the results of those Recons a lot of
this were you know hand recounts of
voting machine
elections I don't know how many we're
voting machine left but there were you
know these were hand count re recounts
were there very many discrepancies
it depends on what you call a
discrepancy I mean there was some
movement in the numbers between
candidates but for the most part the
recounts affirmed the results of the
election Night results
there were a couple of races that
flipped
um one yeah was a little controversial
because I uh
decided to continue to recount the
Manchester Ward 6 because based on the
information that
we had been required to collect by the
legislature coupled with uh audit which
by chance happened to be that Ward you
know it was very obvious looking at the
numbers that not all of the ballots have
been counted in that race during the
recount and so you know I had a very
difficult
decision and that was you know do you
let the results stand from the recount
or
you know do you make sure the votes are
counted and so I made the decision
to count the rest of the votes that
forced a court issue which is where that
should have ended up uh and we had
resolution to it but
um but for the most part the numbers
were within a range that you would
expect to see after an election when
when ballot counting devices are
counting ballots
you sacrificed a little bit of accuracy
for Speed because the machine will not
read
a ballot or a mark on a ballot that is
not in the proper place even though
looking at the ballot you can determine
what the voter intent was and so there
are differences it wouldn't be unusual
for a town like Merrimack to have
everybody's votes go up maybe 20 votes
because of that
um
but that's why we have recounts you know
if the race is close and people have
questions they can easily request a
recount we had a record number of
recounts by the way 31 have been
requested
further questions
okay uh representative Brennan
thank you for taking my question
it's on your knowledge and it experience
our New Hampshire election
elect safe secure and have long history
of producing reliable trustworthy
results yes
further questions from the committee
thank you for saying none thank you
we're going to close the um I'm sorry I
got to do the blue sheet
um was it aikenberg you give me the blue
sheet does anyone else wish to speak to
House Bill oh my goodness I lost my spot
uh house bill
thank you five uh 5.99
okay thank you
uh on the blue sheet there are one two
three people signed in favor and one two
three people signed as a post uh with
that I will close the Committee hearing
on House Bill 599 and I will open the
Committee hearing on House Bill 259 only
a solid hour and 10 minutes behind
schedule uh relative to the study of
making working at polling places on
Election Day a civic responsibility and
legal obligation for Citizens
um House Bill 259 I don't believe I have
a pink card for house bill 259. yes
bring it up here
thank you so much
you're up yeah but yeah
all right thank you very much I'd like
to thank the members of the committee
for this opportunity to speak in favor
of House Bill 259 uh when I was a kid I
grew up in central Vermont a couple of
hours from here well more than that from
here a couple hours from where I live
um and you know one of the great uh
memories of of my youth is going to town
meeting day uh once a year my parents
always went my brother and I uh
volunteered at town meeting day running
the microphones around so everybody
could uh it could be heard and it was a
great introduction to kind of New
England democracy direct democracy votes
over you know what road is going to get
graded this year and if we buy a new
fire truck and and things like that
um and one of the things you know we
would stay afterwards my parents
volunteered and counted uh votes and uh
one of the things I learned from that
about hand counting for example is even
when you're looking at like 80 votes in
a small town
there are going to be miscounts right
three or four recounts of the same 80
votes in order to figure out whether or
not you're going to buy a fire truck so
it speaks in ways to the
um
not always accurate results of hand
counting even small numbers of votes
we have a really special culture
political culture here in New Hampshire
which is why some of us feel very
passionately about New Hampshire's
statuses first in the nation
primary we have high voter turnout
compared to a lot of other states we
also have high voter confidence but at
the moment we also do have a relatively
high level of voter distrust in the
accuracy of our elections as we've just
heard quite a bit about
the Constitution of the United States
guarantees us a right to trial by jury
right and so we have a jury system
because it is our Collective
responsibility to participate in that
process we have a right and we have a
responsibility right
uh the bill that I presented uh 259 is
intended to have us think about voting
in similar terms this is a you know one
of our most precious constitutional
rights uh and uh I think that there's
some opportunity to think here about the
responsibilities that come along with
participating in that system having
those rights and having certain
responsibilities uh I have uh friends in
in Germany I am by training my
profession is is a German historian and
they have requirements to work at polls
on election days
uh and that is in part for Germany it's
a really important kind of development
in their civic culture in response to
the problems with authoritarianism in
their past but election day there is uh
it's a day off uh and uh they have a
system whereby people have to it's it's
not tied into the jury system like uh
like I'm proposing here uh but is uh
people have to serve on a regular basis
working at polls on election days
uh and there are a number of
aspects of our current political culture
I think that could be served really well
by thinking about
our participation in elections in ways
that are similar to our participation in
the jury process as a right that's
accompanied by responsibility uh first
of all I think it can help address some
of the voter confidence issues
getting people involved in the process
is one of the most effective ways of
making them feel that they have
ownership of the process and to believe
that the the process is accurate in fact
we know I went to one of the the special
commissions meetings in Keene in
September and studies that were
spoken about at that meeting indicate
that The Closer the election is to your
local level the more likely you are to
have confidence in the results right so
if you go from a town to a county to the
state to the National level you see lack
of confidence increase as the distance
from the voter to the election increases
right so uh getting people involved I
think is a potentially a beneficial
result of of this kind of system and
hopefully helping to to raise confidence
by again giving people ownership in the
process
I think overall it it raises the level
of Engagement we have a high voter
turnout in New Hampshire but it is still
you know there are lots of folks who
don't uh vote and certainly it is their
right to not vote just it is is your
right to not Avail yourself of the
constitutional right to trial by jury
and choose a trial by judge if you wish
um but we can increase that level of
Engagement I think that we should all
have that as a goal increasing the
number of our citizens who are legally
eligible to vote uh uh to do so
I also am particularly concerned in
our current culture at what has become
much more so outside of New Hampshire
for sure but a pervasive culture of of
harassment of of poll workers
we have a very divided culture very US
versus them kind of culture uh
politically and that extends in many
ways to how people regard and treat poll
workers if they feel that somehow the
system is being rigged they tend to
regard the people who are actually
participating in the civic duty and and
responsibility of working at the polls
they tend to regard them as the them
that are somehow
undermining your right and so I think
that having a system like this where
people uh average citizens like
ourselves are brought into the uh the
polling place to work uh hopefully is
going to help break down that US versus
them mentality that makes unfortunately
a lot of people feel that they have
license to abuse poll workers while they
themselves do nothing to participate in
the system that they stand by and
criticize
so I see these as a number of of
beneficial outcomes of
thinking about
having something comparable to our jury
system with regard guard to poll workers
I think there are a lot of ways that
this could play out I had a great
meeting with the secretary of state
where we threw back and forth some
different scenarios well what about this
what about that those details obviously
would need to be worked out that's why
this bill provides for a special
committee uh that would then
potentially charge the Secretary of
State's office with doing a feasibility
study but those are what I see as the
benefits of thinking about working at
polls differently uh and I'm happy to
take your questions and look forward to
an opportunity to engage in conversation
about uh about my bill
thank you um questions from the
committee reminder this is a bill to
form a committee to issue the Secretary
of State to start a commission so keep
the contents of how the bill please
I successfully batted down the questions
perfect thank you representative uh I
don't have anyone else to speak other
than secretary Scanlon um so secretary
Scanlon three minutes on the bill to
form a committee to force you to have a
commission
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David Scanlon Secretary of
State and I'm happy to support this bill
I did have a good conversation with
representative germana about his idea
and I think it dovetails nicely into
the ability to vote to to
build voter confidence
in the state you know one of the ways
that you do that in addition to being
transparent is you educate the voting
population on exactly how the voting
process works and there's no better way
to do that than to actually participate
as a poll worker and work in the polling
place
so you know I think it might be a lot to
ask
to have a a jury pull type selection
process where you're mandated to work on
the day of the election but there might
be a variation of it where individuals
can be selected at random and asked if
they want to participate on the day of
the election and there may be other ways
to encourage
participation of potential poll workers
so I'll stop there and answer any
questions
okay questions from the committee
uh we'll go with representative Hamer
thank you for taking my question
now these people that are like juried
people
they're going to have to go through
training right
they should
um but you know the current process
right now does not require that
um and if
if the moderator or the clerk or the
Selectmen are looking for people to
conduct an election if they don't have
enough experienced staff they have to
pull from somewhere to get the job done
and
uh you know this type of effort might be
a way for people to ease into that
process
representative Muirhead we had heard
from you so much today you know
should I should I should I sit back
really for the rest of the day I think
I'm in a penalty box excuse me Mr
secretary thank you Mr Vice chair
um
do you would so this would be a way of
kind of in there you know one one thing
would be to force people to serve and
and like we do kind of force people to
serve on juries another be to invite
them to volunte to to step forward
um how about would you favor other ways
of getting people to voluntarily offer
themselves like paying them more or you
know using public service announcements
on radio stations to invite people to
volunteer something like that before
doing this
kind of commission or committee to form
a commission
the short answer is yes
um you know we when we're looking at
ways that we can encourage more poll
worker participation and there's one
there is one uh initiative that I'm
looking at right now which is
encouraging veterans who have served
their country uh you know fought to
defend the right to vote and in their
older years of retirement years
encouraged them to come and actually
participate in that process and I'm
pretty excited about that but there's
other ways to achieve the same goal and
you know I'm open to what those might be
representative wood
thank you Mr chair I'm new to this
committee and I'm not trying to be
funny here but uh since you seem to be
ahead uh okay with putting this
committee together can I just recommend
itl and let you do your job am I missing
something here I'm not sure I'm not
trying to be flipping so if I am I
apologize
we we would work on this on this anyway
um but sometimes the study committee can
you know bring
more people together who have different
ideas and and uh you know things come up
that I might not think of and how that
process might work but the short answer
is yes we would be working on this
anyway okay thank you
representative weary
you mentioned the veterans again what a
great idea
how about for secondary education where
you have high school individuals who are
you know may have to do a senior project
or community service project this could
align with Civics instructions and the
secretary's secondary schools what's the
possibility of doing something like that
similar to what you're proposing for the
use of the veterans in that capacity
I think that's a great idea currently in
statute 17 year olds are allowed to
actually work in a polling place as an
election official
there have been
small initiatives in the past to try and
develop that a little bit further and
they haven't taken off but we should get
our youth involved early because once
they start voting they tend to stay
voting and
I think that would be a very positive
thing
representative Burnham
thank you Vice chair thank you Mr
secretary
um
do we know of any other states that make
this a requirement or a civic duty
I'm not aware of any that doesn't mean
there aren't some that exist I just
don't know
um follow-up follow-up please as I uh
working in a Maya local elections for
several years this has always been the
biggest issue is trying to find a
balanced party
volunteer or paid volunteer as you say
so
um would there be any penalties for
people that choose not to if this
process were to take place do we know of
again I you know I think I don't
personally support making it mandatory
for somebody to be selected in a jury
pool type situation but I think that
idea could be used to
send invitations to voters that are
selected at random you know would you
like to participate
uh in the polling place on the day of
the election in service of civic duty
and see if you can you know just get
there you know their their pride to come
forward and you know have them Step Up
sure one more of course just as an
encouragement
um
part of
um some homeschooling students that um
are in my area is to help and provide
food things like that for the poll
workers as just a contribution to them
being there and certainly the idea of
high school students is a great idea
perhaps that would be something to
really March forward with and pushing
forward through our education system
thank you and the
a community can use younger people if
they want to they just can't be election
officials but they could do things like
you know Mana a food table or you know
help
help bring things back and forth to the
election workers
um you know there may be roles that they
can
do in the polling place to make it
easier for everybody else but also give
them some exposure
I'm sure all those questions will be
answered in the committee to form the
commission
any other questions
representative Bay
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
secretary for taking my question uh the
spirit of my question is as someone who
has take paid time off to do this work
um so with with the uh if this is a
civic duty like
um jury duty would it be a requirement
for employers to employ uh
individuals from New Hampshire to allow
their employees to charge their time to
jury duty when they are serving uh
during elections
again you know if it was mandatory
which I don't favor I you know I don't
know I that would have to be developed
in the bill but that's a good question
representative Brennan
thank you for taking my question this
bill
um outlines the membership of the
committee as three members of the house
two members of the Senate if you do you
need legislation to include
to create your own committee as you are
exploring these
um ways where you might
invite more volunteers to become poll
workers do you need
a bill do you need legislation to
involve members of the house or members
of the senate in that exploration
to invite more poll workers no no I
think you know if I wanted to create an
ad hoc committee I could certainly do
that that's the way I created the
special committee on voter confidence
you know which is a fairly high profile
committee but
um
sometimes it's nice to have the
formality of the legislative approval
when you do something like that
thank you Mr Brennan for the most
pointed question about the bill
um any other questions from the
committee
okay
um I will say uh I thought this was
going to be a slam dunk open close and
actually uh proposition it to
representative Lane to execute
immediately clearly there is more
interest than I thought so we are going
to not do that for sure and close the
hearing on um I'm sorry
oh we're gonna do the blue sheet thank
you yes thank you thank you so much
okay
um on House Bill 259 there were
um four people signed up as opposed and
one person signed up in support
now I will close the hearing on a house
bill 259 and I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 395 relative to
the voters guides for Constitutional
Amendments
um I don't believe I have oh I have one
pink car
is the sponsor here
representative Schmidt
is anyone here to introduce this
legislation
um
would it be a disruption of Republican
or Democrat do we not know yes welcome
to the 400 person body
he's a Democrat would one of the members
of the Democrat uh committee would like
to introduce this bill take absolutely
no questions so we can proceed with our
hearing
if it had been a republican I would have
asked the Republican to do it for the
record for the record
and clearly I didn't know
foreign
and by the way thank you representative
Lane for jumping on this one
uh thank you Mr Vice chair my name is
Connie Lane I'm a representative for
Ward 2 in Concord and I am introducing
House Bill 395 on behalf of
Representative Schmidt
uh and it's an act relative to the
voter's guide for Constitutional
Amendments and um I don't think I'm
going to take any questions is there
anyone else who's going to speak to the
bill Mr Vice chair oh okay well then I
defer to all those folks I I think it
will be well covered
um actually you know what
uh we'll start with Liz tantarelli
mostly because I haven't seen you yet I
think this legislative cycle Miss chance
really welcome back
thank you representative Barry it's yes
I I haven't been here testifying yet
whoops untangle myself
thank you my name is Liz tantarelli I'm
president of the non-partisan League of
Women Voters and I did speak with the
sponsor about this bill several weeks
ago
uh and in fact I can't contacted him
because in Fall of 2022 as you know we
had two Constitution two ballot
questions
and there was great confusion among the
public about what the heck these meant
the League of Women Voters goal is to
empower voters and therefore we took it
upon ourselves
to write an explanation of each of the
ballot questions to disseminate that via
email to our members and friends and
supporters via social media via paper
copy at candidate forums in any way we
could do this we sent them out to groups
that requested it and so on
um recently all those extra copies of
that went into the recycling bin but I
had one left which I've given to the
clerk
so I you know if you want to see how we
did a neutral explanation of those two
questions you can
now we did that because we feel that is
our work to empower voters to understand
what they're voting for it's in the same
spirit in which we conduct candidate
forums meet the candidates so you know
whom you're voting for
I we reached a small fraction of the
voters let's let's be honest
people were emailing me asking me
questions you know people I didn't know
were emailing the league with questions
but still it was a small fraction I
believe this is a good Bill I'm speaking
in support of it to have an explanation
of the question right on the ballot
um and it could be written um
very simply it should be written very
simply frankly
for instance the registrar probate thing
had every reference to the registrar
probate deleted because that's that's
your law right now
um so in my explanation I showed it the
way you legislators saw it when it was
passed last year that is as a
strikethrough of the phrase register of
probate
which made a lot more sense now you know
what you're voting for you're voting to
get rid of that position
anyway back back to this bill I do
believe that we should have those kinds
of explanations right on the ballot I
disagree with the sponsor and I tried to
call him over the weekend and didn't
reach him to see if he'd amend it I
disagree that the text of that
explanation should be written by gel
Carr I think that should be written by
the Secretary of State a completely
neutral party in the elections but I do
believe the voters need and deserve
explanations and that's why the league
supports this and if you don't pass this
bill and we get another Constitutional
Amendment on the ballot we'll do the
same thing we did in 2020 we'll write
our own explanation and try to publicize
it but we won't reach nearly the number
that we could if you pass this bill I'd
be glad to answer questions if there are
any questions from the committee
representative wood
representative can you turn your
microphone on
thank you I agree with you that first
one would have been much easier if we
followed what we do here and do a
strikethrough I'm a little nervous about
the explanation because some of these
things get pretty wordy and to make them
completely neutral is very difficult to
do in my opinion but um so my concern
here and you can representative
we have to uh are you I hate to be that
guy because especially people know I I
love a good back and forth but we have
to ask a question in the hearing in the
interest of fairness what is your
consent I'm sorry
Mr chair what is your concern about how
thorough the explanation needs to be
away okay
um the the copy that I gave to the clerk
I think we went overboard in our
explanation
and when I posted it on social media I
simplified it and I said that that first
question for instance would take the
position of register of probate out of
the Constitution because it is a
position which no longer has any duties
and the only way that can be done is
through a constitutional amendment that
that would have been perfectly fine so
when we have cut any controversial
Constitutional Amendment and yes I've
looked at the cacrs for this year
okay we're in for a fun ride with those
um
I don't think it should be gel car that
is writing that because you you have
partisan views there that's why I
suggest that this be amended so that the
secretary of state will write it as
simply as briefly and as neutrally as
possible I hope that answered your
question representative
follow-up did you have you recommended I
think you said about just to be clear
have you made that recommendation to the
sponsor I I couldn't reach him over the
weekend and I'm I'm not sure why and I'm
not sure why he's not here that was my
intention to recommend it to him that
that did answer my question thank you so
much thank you representative wooden I
hope we're still friends representative
Bay
thank you Mr chair for and thank you for
taking my question good to see you
um so what is
um the downside to uh just um keeping it
as is where uh non-partisan groups such
as the League of Women Voters provide
that information I'd love to thank you
for that question and I love your
confidence in us that we could reach a
lot of Voters we can't it needs to be on
the ballot there are certainly people
who
missed any newspaper reference to this
missed our social media missed our
handouts we're there in the polling
place and had no understanding of either
of the questions and whether their yes
or no votes mattered and what they
should do
so it needs to be on the ballot
further questions from the committee
okay seeing none and it's good seeing
you again miss tantarelli thank you
representative Barry next up uh Roy I
I'm going to butcher this last name so I
apologize uh shwake swaker you're gonna
have to help me from Concord
Pat schweiker is Germanic it's like
schweitz and other German names you
pronounce the second letter instead of
the first but anyway yes I'm Roy
schweiker from Concord and she actually
stole a lot of my thunder
because
I felt the same way about the
Constitutional Amendment thing that you
know it didn't really say anything it
was made worse by the Concord Monitor
the day before the election said the
effect of this amendment would be remove
the register of deeds
so
so you know the I I agree with what she
said in terms of we should have an
explanation it should be on the ballot
and more importantly and once again it
sort of says this here but not quite the
amendment should say what will change
what the impact of this is is compared
to what will happen afterward because
what was presented was correct after how
it happened only if only a certain
offices would appear in the Constitution
but it didn't say that the impact of
this is you'd be removing a presently
existing office so I think that that's
the second important thing is that you
need to show what's changing and not
just what the result is
and I have a second story here the
Concord School District had a charter
commission last time through
and they decided on their own that they
wanted to eliminate the uh requirement
the charter commission candidates file
campaign Finance requirements and also
the requirement that they'd be elected
by Awards instead of at Large
so they
they had an amendment to the Charter
that would do those two things but once
again they did not say in the
explanation that we're going to
eliminate the campaign Finance
requirement we're going to change to our
large voting they just said what the
result was so most people who voted on
it had no clue what was actually taking
place in this thing so that's once again
an example of why it's very important
that the requirement for the explanation
show what the change is and not what the
result is
and lastly to get to the last topic here
I think the joint legislative committee
on administrative rules maybe should
approve the text I mean the people that
came up with it originally you know
maybe know what it should be but the
joint committee on rules you know could
look at it and see is this like the
charter commission they're trying to
hide something we need to fix this and
the other thing that came up with the
charter commission is the only appeal
was to the Superior Court you could
appeal to the superior court if you
didn't like it that's probably not
something they have a great deal of
expertise in and gosh knows when they
would have had a hearing you know maybe
two or three years from now after the
Amendments already end so I think that
the correct thing to do may be to do
this
that whoever writes the amendment
provides the explanation but the
committee on legislative rules gets to
review it and object if they don't like
it and the Secretary of State who
actually is our top election official
and if he can set the primary date he
got to be able to be the final decision
on you know whether the explanation is
correct
and the last thing I want to say
extending what she has said is this just
says that if the legislature or whatever
proposes the change that this
explanation has to meet this requirement
but if it comes by a constitutional
commission they don't you don't have to
go through this I think the change
should be the same for everybody that
the Constitutional commission may write
an explanation but it should be subject
to review by
administrative rules if you want to and
certainly the Secretary of State can
make the final determination of this is
this a fair
you know explanation that explains
what's actually changing rather than
you're trying to hide something and then
I'll make one more last thing and that
is why is this only true for
Constitutional Amendments why isn't it
true for any such change why don't we
make Charter commissions subject to if
they propose an explanation that's not
you know full and correct that the
Secretary of State can change it and you
and if somebody a voter doesn't like the
explanation they appeal to the Secretary
of State who can actually affect the
ballot rather than paying several
hundred dollars to get the Superior
Court to rule on it three years from now
thank you
thank you questions from the committee
seeing none thank you
next up Mary till also from Concord
Concord well represented today
thank you Mr Vice chair and committee
members
um my name is Mary Chill and I'm from
Concord as you pointed out and I am
rising in favor of this bill actually I
worked with representative Smith in
writing this bill and I have a couple of
comments related to that but first of
all let's talk about my motivation in
wanting in the bill to be written and I
agree pretty much with what the previous
speakers have said I used to be a town
moderator in Dairy until 2020 and so a
lot of people looked to me when it came
to election questions and I got lots of
calls from people saying what's going on
with these amendments especially that
first one
in fact one person said you know if you
remember the bill there was a section
71a and a section 71 B e both of which
just removed the rep the Registrar of
probate from the Constitution and they
looked at that and they said well I want
to vote no on 71a but I want to vote Yes
171b you know how do I vote and uh
so I you know explained to them
how
um I mean what was really going on with
this amendment but when I got the first
call it it happened to go to my
voicemail so uh somebody was saying you
know explain to me what's happening on
this amendment and I thought well okay
I'm going to read it because I hadn't
read it I'd heard that there was going
to be an amendment to remove the
Registrar of probate
so I went uh I went to the sample ballot
that I had and I read the Constitutional
Amendment and I said I don't know what
this one's all about doesn't say
anything about registrar probate but
luckily I had a a handy dandy copy of
the New Hampshire Constitution so I
pulled it out and I read the relevant
sections and realized what they had done
so when I called the people back and
explained that they they were satisfied
but my concern is although I'm glad they
trust me I really don't think that
voters should have to trust somebody
they know to understand how they're
voting and so that's when I went to
representative Schmidt and said we need
to put an explanation on the ballot of
what these amendments mean I know from
town politics that when they put out a
Warren article they do put an
explanation of what the warrant is all
about and so I didn't understand why it
wasn't happening for the with the New
Hampshire Constitution
the other thing is
after the bill was submitted I started
hearing lots of talk about who's writing
this explanation in fact the the
analysis of the bill says it changes the
process of drafting voter guides for
Constitutional Amendments well that was
never the intention it has nothing we
don't care who writes these explanations
so
um Senator representative Schmidt and I
got together over the weekend I don't
know if he was able to offer an
amendment but we did come up with an
amendment that basically leaves
663 colon 3 hyphen a which talks about
how this
this explanation is included in the C
cacr
and then it is you know taken from there
and the explanation is
given to the Secretary of State who puts
it in the voter's guide that's fine so
the amendment that we're going to
propose will simply not touch
part A which talks about who's going to
write it we'll do it the way we're doing
it right now it adds a new section that
says the text of the statement for the
voter's guide and the resolution
proposing the Constitutional Amendment
as described in RSA 663 colon 3 hyphen a
shall be printed on the election day
ballot immediately beneath the
Constitutional question to which it
applies so that
gets rid of all of the discussion about
who's going to write it we're not trying
to deal with that question now somebody
can put in another another bill if you
want to do that but this bill is just to
talk about getting an explanation on the
ballot so I'll be happy to answer any
questions
okay questions from the committee
easy enough thank you Miss till
next up Carol oh Lord uh
thank you also from Concord once again
conquered extremely Representatives
today
I apologize about your last name oh
I am Carol canarium and
Anna come and talk to you today
um I have a master's degree and I'm
reasonably intelligent but when I go
into the polls I often do not understand
the question or if I understand the
question sometimes I just don't quite
know whether voting yes is agreeing or
voting yes is not agreeing
so
um when I went to the polls in November
and I I had read in the in the monitor
about the bills and of the questions and
I was pretty clear that I knew but there
was no mention of probate in that
question it was and other people that I
talked to just didn't understand it at
all and they too reported that they
often didn't understand questions or
that they were confused about how to
answer it so I thought oh this has to
change so I am just delighted to have
this bill
um I think it's really important for
voters to have clear statements about
what the bill is and how when you vote
that you know that you're voting it the
way you really believe you should vote
it and I think if we wrote that bill so
that a fifth grader could understand it
and tell me what's in it that would be
wonderful
so I think really and truly it should be
on the ballot and I think if the
question has to be in some legal
language that's fine but underneath
there should be a place for voters who
are not legal people and they could know
what they're voting for
so thank you very much I am very happy
to be talking to you actually not many
people say that
questions from the committee
okay well thank you
um last pink card we have is from the
Secretary of State's office deputy
secretary Hennessey
thank you Mr
committee good to see all of you again
um I have not seen the proposed
amendment that the last speaker was
talking to but just bringing up a couple
of points that other people have spoken
to already
Not only was the two questions
especially one of them very confusing
for some of our voters this past year
the actual voters guide was confusing as
well and we did get a few angry phone
calls to the Secretary of State's office
since we do print that and distribute it
to your town election officials we put
it up on our website but we can only
print
currently what it says that we can print
so we don't have any way to make that a
little bit clearer to what the voter's
doing so
um I'm not sure what the amendment does
but looking at this a a new process just
to make sure that that voters guide is
clearer would be recommended by myself I
think that that can be worked on just to
make sure that whatever is given to the
voter they have they do understand what
they're what they're voting on
um the other the other thing that this
bill currently does is that it prints
that voter's guide on the ballot and we
don't do that right now if you were in
your polling location in November you
may have seen the voter's guide for the
questions or if you had an absentee
ballot you may have gotten one in the
mail
putting the voter guide on the question
I just want to make you aware would make
the ballot longer possibly because it
would add a lot more language to the
bill so however the committee decides to
address this bill I just want to make
you aware of that possible ballot a
bigger Ballot or a more expensive ballot
process process
that's all I have to say Okay questions
from the committee representative wood
thank you Mr chair
um what are what are the legal
restrictions you mentioned that you're
confined now about legal restrictions
what you could put on the ballot is that
something you could just say quickly yes
so if you look at the bill in front of
you and you take out all of the strikes
and all of the bolds that's what the
current law is
so we print what the legislation tells
us to print
thank you
further questions representative
Muirhead thank you
um how seriously should we take the
longer ballot
um concern but you're just off the cuff
one might think that a slightly longer
ballot that voters can understand is
better than a shorter ballot that
confuses the heck out of Voters what's
your take
my take is that it's your decision I
just wanted to bring it to your
attention that it may be a bigger ballot
and if there's if there's a lot of
candidates on the ballot and the
questions get a little bit longer with a
little bit longer description and that
doesn't fit on in an eight and a half by
14 or eight and a half by 18 inch ballot
there could be two two ballots there
could be two pages just
it's hard to predict what the new
legislatures will bring before us and
what could possibly be printed on the
ballot
representative
thank you Mr chair so
um piggybacking off of that there's
nothing that would prevent us from
passing dozens or dozens and dozens of
uh Constitutional Amendments and having
them appear on the ballot that's correct
the fall
follow so in in that case we would in we
could potentially encounter a longer
ballot anyway
that is correct just from term to term
yes yep I just again it was just for
your information
further questions
okay that's it thank you uh deputy
secretary can we get the blue sheet see
I remember this time
and then we're almost playing catch up
almost almost
thank you so much there are three people
signed in
um three in support uh none against two
of them spoke so I know the the chairman
normally subtracts those two out but
that's okay uh with that I will close
the public hearing on House Bill
395 and I will open the house uh the the
hearing uh the Committee hearing on
House Bill 502 relative to voter
affidavit ballots
um I don't believe I have a pink card
from the sponsor of the submit which
there are many
foreign
no interest in this one at all
that's the sponsor uh yes that is
perfect
okay uh representative Mike Edgar from
Hampton who has indicated he needs two
plus questions
and welcome to election law
representative
uh thank you very much uh as you said my
name is Mike EDD you and I do represent
Hampton in the New Hampshire house
um and thank you uh Mr chairman and
members of the committee for allowing me
to introduce hb502 to you today
this bill repeals last year's
legislation that was in SB 418.
SB 418 uh you know was a bill that
created Hampton excuse me New
Hampshire's first provisional ballot law
and in my opinion introduced concern and
confusion into the process for elected
officials and voters
I want to start by saying that I usually
do not find myself in front of you you
probably haven't seen me in here
normally I'm dealing with roads and
bridges or something like that
um
but I but I am a veteran and when I
learned about how this law had the
potential to negatively affect overseas
military voters ability to cast a ballot
I felt compelled to act and
submit this bill
last year the committee heard a lot
about uh
uoca VA or the uniformed overseas
citizens absentee boating Act
the ACT requires that
you owe a c a v a ballots be sent a
minimum of 45 days before the general
election
and that's for federal elections
SB 418 was written to uh provides a vote
of seven days to return proof of
identity to have their balance count
however it still allows 14 days for the
certification of any provisional ballots
okay
which is eight short weeks between the
primary and general election if an
election official used the full 14 days
it would cause New Hampshire to be in
violation of the federal law there this
could result in military personnel using
their opportunity to cast a ballot
let me be clear I I do not believe
anyone in this committee wants that to
happen uh but it exactly what could
happen uh when this law is an act that
is written
additionally uh we are now just three
short weeks from Rochester special
election in less than two months from
town meeting day
in a local election officials have yet
to receive any specific guidance from
the Secretary of State office on how
this new system would be implemented
that's the one I wrote this maybe he
gave it today election officials still
have not seen a packet they will give to
the voters including the overnight
Prepaid U.S Postal Service priority mail
package Francis overnight delivery
envelopes addressed to the Secretary of
State
Capital forms it must have to be filled
out in a checklist to make sure that all
officials are performing all steps
correct and in a uniform manner
so that would be throughout the whole
state
Rochester is also another good example
of a fundamental flaw in this bill what
happens if the special election once
again ends in a tie but one or two
voters use their new provisional ballot
system
what if a candidate wins by one or only
to see that the wind disappeared due to
two ballots removed from the count
it has been said many times over the
past few months that New Hampshire does
elections right
in no small part because we get results
right away
this law has the potential to jeopardize
that
there will be several other individuals
that will testify to their concerns
about the changes taking effect January
1st 2023 as a result of the
implementation of SB 418
New Hampshire is and should be proud of
its elections the UNH poll after this
past election said that 92 percent of
the voters have faith in our elections
our elections are well run and our
voters have confidence in them
SB 418 could cause that confidence to
shriek with implementation confusion
delayed results and people's voting
votes not counting
but thank you and please consider voting
OTP on Bill HB 502
and repeal this provisional ballot law
and with that that concludes my written
testimony and if anybody has any
questions I'd be more than happy to give
them a shot questions from the committee
I'm president thank you representative
I'm sorry okay you are all set I thought
reps in your head was signaling me
got me again on your head
thank you uh next up will be Ed
Frederick Fred Reich well I'm I'm just
I'm just running over names today
good afternoon as I said my name is Ed
Frederick I live in Loudon and I'm a
former officer with the United States
Marine Corps uh and served during
Vietnam
um absentee voting started in the War of
1812 and the Civil War to give service
members the ability to exercise the
right for which they were willing to
sacrifice all
for the past two decades our service
members deployed to the Middle East and
other theaters have been able to vote
via absentee ballot
but a bill passed by this year's
legislation SB 418
makes it more difficult for our service
men and women deployed around the world
to make their voices heard and vote even
as they protect that right with our
country
as a military veteran and I'm a
grandfather of an active U.S Navy
service member from New Boston
I want to request your support for HP
which will overturn SB 418
the bill that has created new
complicated voting rules that will
directly limit the opportunity for
members of the military station overseas
to guess their ballots
SB 418 makes it nearly impossible for
New Hampshire's local election officials
to mail ballots to active duty military
voters for future general elections in
line with Federal requirements
it will needlessly complicate New
Hampshire's election process
and may delay certification of winners
of New Hampshire primary elections
starting in 2024 for weeks
it has also felt that SB 418 likely
violates federal law that protects
military voters
the uniform and overseas citizens
absentee Voting Act uacava
a federal law that determines processes
for members of the military to cast
their ballot requires ballots to be
mailed to military voters 45 days before
a federal election
that means that local election officials
are required to mail general election
ballots to military members only a few
days after and possibly even before
primary election results are certified
under SB 418.
this creates an impossible task for
local election officials and may
ultimately restrict our armed service
members from casting their ballots
supporters have claimed that SB 418 will
improve the sanctity of Elections and
improve voter confidence
but many veterans Town clerks Secretary
of State and the ACLU and others
testified in opposition maintaining that
this bill attempts to solve a problem
that does not exist
their testimony in that of the Secretary
of State Mr Scanlon who suggested
tabling SB 418 and asking the state
supreme court for an opinion
of its constitutionality was not enough
to put the brakes in this legislation
was less than two years before the next
election now is not the time to make our
local election officials job more
difficult
as they already faced many unneeded
threats and complications to run our
elections it is also not the time to
limit opportunities for members of the
military to participate in the Democracy
they are safeguarding
with more New Hampshire service members
being deployed
and with to NATO countries in Eastern
Europe due to the war in Ukraine
we cannot and should not make it make
voting even more difficult for them
I ask you to move HP 502 as ought to
pass out of this committee
I can't even imagine how absurdly
terrible it would be if there was even
one service member's vote nullified
because the restrictions imposed by
sp418
. thank you for your time and attention
to this very important issue
questions from the committee
um I have a question um first of all
thank you for your service I'm the son
of a Vietnam veteran who has a bronze
star and as my dad told me I would never
meet a Vietnam veteran welcome home
um your concerns as your testimony are
about the you will clava deadline which
is the 45-day mail out before a general
election uh the absentee about has to be
mailed out your concerns for SB 418
peeling the affidavit ballot are about
that deadline is constrained and we'd be
violating federal law if the primary
date was moved
those concerns about yokava would be
mute because we would be able to finish
it so would you still have concerns
about the bill if the primary date was
moved in the uokava concern was dealt
with
um I'd really rather not answer that
thank you
okay next up uh Bob Perry from Stratford
thank you Mr Vice chair and members of
the committee
I speak in support of hb502
as you know this bill repeals Provisions
relative to voter affidavit ballots
found in current law derived from SB 418
which is currently in litigation
if it takes as long for the courts to
resolve the current case as it did sb3
in 2017 four years
the current law will remain in effect
for multiples of election Cycles
if it is overturned an unknown multiple
of Voters will have been unduly burdened
and perhaps intimidated simply
exercising their right under the New
Hampshire Constitution to vote
another unknown number of eligibles will
have been provided incorrect information
about the process by friends
relatives neighbors or social media and
decided that the process was too
complicated contradicted or too
misunderstood by them to safely
participate
passage of hb502 will
one simplify the voting process and
protect voter privacy because it does
not require use of traceable ballots
the secret ballot is also our sacred
ballot two eliminate what the state of
New Hampshire has vigorously and
admirably opposed over many years the
use of provisional ballots
3 eliminate concerns over our Motor
Voter exception maintaining use of
same-day registration which we have used
continuously since 1993.
or jeopardize our first in the nation
status because our status is always
vulnerable to hijacking by other states
we know now it is under review at the
federal level
hb502 puts us in a better position to
wad off the challenges
five eliminate the possibility that a
voter could not Rectify his or her
identity within the mandatory seven-day
period due to consequences beyond the
voter's control
administrative bureaucracy delayed
mailings the unforeseen
six eliminate concerns over the known
short yokava deadlines
we often think of you okava voters as
being military personnel stationed
overseas but we know it also includes
New Hampshire civilians who work
overseas
seven absolve the moderator or clerk
from the penalty of perjury when either
vouches for the legitimacy of a Voda
we know Granite State taxpayers gave up
3.35 million dollars for the state to
defend sb3 which figure does not include
4176 billable hours by the AG's office
and we know the total outside legal cost
was 4.2 million
on the other hand we know from the
fiscal note on 502 that repeal of
current law will save Granite State
taxpayers 178 thousand dollars in fiscal
year 2024
and 354 000 in fiscal year 2025.
lastly it is safe to predict that the
longer the lawsuit on the current law
exists though more public dollars will
be spent by the AG's office and to other
entities to defend it
I urge OTP on hb502 and I thank you
the questions from the committee
thank you Mr Perry
uh next up Matt mushin from Claremont
welcome to election law
thank you
good afternoon members of the committee
uh my name is Matt musian I live in
Claremont where I serve as a city
councilor and today I'm here
representing 603 forward a nonpartisan
non-profit organization dedicated to
empowering and building young folks in
New Hampshire
uh I'm here today to testify in support
of House Bill 502 which would repeal the
provisional ballot system put into law
this year
um the new provisional ballot system
creates unnecessary confusion and
complicates the voting process
disproportionately
burdening the right to vote for working
age Granite Staters and Military voters
who are predominantly younger which is
why I would urge the committee to vote
ought to pass on House Bill 502
the original ballot system has done
really nothing to improve our elections
and it was founded from a place rooted
in conspiracies which sought only to
weaken faith in our elections
um and I would also say that in the last
presidential election 50 of working age
voters aged 18 to 29 participated and
took went to the went to the polls to
vote
and this new provisional ballot system
would only make it harder for working
age voters to participate in the
Democratic process by making same-day
voter registration a more difficult and
burdening process
additionally by implementing a
provisional ballot system as a means to
track someone's vote there are new
threats to our ballot security and
privacy because these provisional
ballots will now have a unique number
connecting them to the name of a voter
meaning that in a small town or a small
City like Claremont your community
members who work at the polls may know
who you voted for
as you've heard the provisional ballot
system also will make it harder for
military members their families and
other U.S citizens living outside of the
country to vote and last year several
high-profile former senior military
leaders in over two dozen local election
officials had vocally opposed the
legislation that created the provisional
ballot system
and I would add that military leaders in
our local election officials know the
importance of a free and fair election
perhaps better than anyone and House
Bill 502 would honor their service by
protecting the right to vote and making
sure that overseas military members are
included in our democracy no matter
where they serve
these are just some of the concerns we
have around the provisional ballot
system and the struggles it will put in
place for young people exercising their
constitutional right to vote
and by creating unnecessary confusion
and further complicating the process
we're concerned that the provisional
ballot system may result in voters
feeling too intimidated or burdened to
participate in the process
after all while this new law is in place
and we are just weeks out from an
election local election officials still
do not have any guidance on how to
implement this new law and that should
be that should be concerns for members
of this committee
I've worked at my local polling location
before and I know that our election
officials work very hard to ensure
Granite State elections are safe and
secure
these these additional needless and
confusing systems will only serve to
bird in our local local election
officials and confuse everyone involved
confusion leads to longer lines which
are proven to disenfranchise eligible
voters
so I hope that this body will continue
to prioritize making it easier for
people to participate in the Bedrock of
our democracy a free and fair election
and please vote ought to pass on House
Bill 502. thank you very much for your
time and consideration
questions from the committee
um I have one
um you said in your testimony we'll put
military voters aside yokova is an issue
of the primary date
um you said it would this bill would if
we did not repeal if we don't pass HP
502 it would make it more burdensome uh
towards people how
well because what's the I guess my
question is what is the burden
of that this is trying to remove
so what you'll now be have forced faced
with is taking a packet with you after
if you do not meet the requirements of a
same-day voter registration and having
to follow up with that after which I
think presents an additional burden
because you know folks have schedules if
you're perhaps going to be out of town
if there's if there's any issue with you
returning that packet of information
um your ballot would then be discounted
so I think that that presents an
additional burden and I think also there
are burdens on our local election
officials who need to continue to
maintain the system and make sure that
people are moving through it in an
efficient manner okay so so what makes
the the voters on Election Day that are
getting this packet what are they doing
that's getting them this packet in this
affidavit ballot what have they
forgotten
so they are registering to vote for the
first time and they've forgotten some
form of uh limited one of the one of the
requirements necessary to be able to
vote that day okay all right thank you
thank you any other questions
thank you oh I apologize representative
Howard I missed you
uh thank you Mr veischer and uh thank
you for coming uh and testifying today I
wanted to ask how uh this bill would
affect students
that's a great that's a good question so
you know uh oftentimes one of the
reasons that young folks may need to uh
register to vote on election days
because they've come here for school or
their new student so for anyone who's
coming here uh to vote or who is newly
18 is in as a student would need to be
able to register at the poll on Election
Day so by repealing uh the provisional
ballot law uh it removes some of the
burdens put in place from from that law
thank you piggybacking on representative
Howard so if this student that's
registering on Election Day brought
their ID they'd still be able to
register to vote and they wouldn't get
an affidavit balance is that correct if
they had all the necessary requirements
yes okay thank you
I think now we're done
um next up is McKinsey St German St
Germain I missed the eye I apologize I'm
you're not the first name to get you
know you know your handwriting's fine
you're just not the first name I've run
over Unfortunately today
good afternoon
um I'm Mackenzie St Germain I'm the
campaign director for the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights which is a
project of America votes New Hampshire
um the New Hampshire campaign for voting
rights is a nonpartisan Coalition we are
committed to protecting voter access and
voting rights as well as modernizing our
elections in New Hampshire and I'm here
today in support of hb502 which would
repeal the provisions of SB 418 which
were passed last year from the time that
SB 418 began working its way through the
legislature in 2022 the New Hampshire
campaign for voting rights was outspoken
about our concerns SB 418 makes same-day
registration more difficult for voters
not everyone has an ID not everyone
remembers to bring their ID with them
for various reasons makes that more
complicated for voters
um and also is a burden on our election
officials who now must administer this
legislation I know the New Hampshire
town and Clerk's Association in 2022 was
opposed to this legislation and can
probably tell you more about the
specific burden on those election
officials
one of the issues with SB 418 and the
new Provisions we have now is the threat
to secret ballots as was talked about
before if in a small town one person
cast their uh affidavit ballot because
they don't have their ID with them they
leave with a packet of information it's
very easy to see a world in which you
see your neighbor leaving with this
extra packet of information you know
that they cost a affidavit ballot you
know 10 days two weeks later you see
those numbers of the results change and
you all of a sudden know who your
neighbor voted for and that is a direct
threat to the secrecy of each individual
voter's ballot
um another issue which obviously has
been brought up multiple times today is
the threat to our military their
families serving overseas and the
timeline of this bill
um which would make right now with the
primary a challenge of you know getting
those yokava ballots over to our
overseas
um folks in time and making sure that
their votes are cast and are counted in
time because of that the yukava deadline
and making sure that there's plenty of
time to get those ballots back I don't
think anyone has any interest in
disenfranchising our overseas military
but that in the way that the bill is
passed currently is that exactly what it
does
um and as it's been said today as well
and I want to repeat everything but uh
this legislation does not yet have we
don't have guidance for voters I looked
on the Secretary of State's website
today it says that you can cast a ballot
even if you go to register at the polls
without an ID you can sign an affidavit
that is no longer the case and we really
need that guidance for our local
election officials and for voters as we
are three weeks ahead of an election in
Rochester
um and just months you know less than a
couple months away from uh the town
meeting day so for those reasons um many
more I ask that you support hb502 and
I'm happy to answer any questions
on the committee
okay seeing none thank you so much
um we'll go up with uh Henry Clement oh
man Henry I just butchered your name
again and I've said your name too
Henry clemento wits whiz
ah man I should know by now too because
it's very good
good afternoon uh members of the
committee my name is Henry clementowicz
I'm a senior staff attorney at the
American civil liberties Union of New
Hampshire
um I've been in one capacity or another
uh Council in five of the last uh voting
rights lawsuits in the state
um and this is a large part of my job
uh ACLU of New Hampshire opposed 418
last session uh because we thought it
was bad policy and because uh we thought
it was unconstitutional enough for a few
reasons and so we support this effort to
repeal it we are also Council in one of
the two Consolidated challenges to SP
418 that was being heard by judge Temple
yesterday in Hillsboro Superior Court
um in addition to being I think bad
policy in that it's really a solution in
search of a problem by imposing new
requirements on voters that are not
supported by I think any rational
um
uh State interest uh there I just wanted
to alert the committee to three of the
uh potential constitutional informa
infirmities that are being in the
process of being presented to the court
one involves the deadline for certifying
elections within five days in part two
article 32 of the New Hampshire
Constitution
uh this bill by requiring the
retabulation of certain votes after
between 7 and 14 days after the election
and then potentially delaying the
recounts for those elections one of the
claims is that that violates part two
article 32
there is a uh a framework a legal
framework called Anderson Burdick which
is named after two U.S Supreme Court
cases that as a framework used by
federal courts and by our state court
and how to evaluate burdens placed on
voters it's a sliding scale where the
interests in the state that the state
has in advancing a law are weighed
against the burdens placed on voters
that that challenge is being presented
to the court and then the third one
involves part one article 2B which is
the governmental
um the protection inherent in New
Hampshire citizens personal and private
data against unreasonable governmental
intrusion and so in this case because
the moderators and or members of the
Secretary of State's office compile a
list with names associated with
affidavit ballot numbers and then later
link those affidavit ballot numbers with
the way in individual votes if they
don't return ID there's a claim being
presented to the court that that is a
governmental intrusion into that
personal private information of how
someone votes so
um I don't I don't want to repeat what
others have said except to say that it's
my view and it continues to be our
position that this law is
unconstitutional for a myriad reasons
and its unwise policy and it should be
repealed so I'm happy to take any
questions
okay I I I'm surprised you're making out
there with no questions but all right
thank you last up is Liz tantarelli from
Newbury
and the league one voters I should say
thank you again for allowing me to speak
my name is Liz tentarelli I'm president
of the nonpartisan League of Women
Voters of New Hampshire and I live in
the little town of Newbury
uh 2 100 voters
and we're all proud of voting and I've
been in my town
um a
Trustee of the library for 12 years I'm
not currently but I have been in my town
so my written testimony includes a lot
of my views on the original SB 418 bill
and the League's objections to it but I
want to focus on the fact that we've got
a special election coming up in
Rochester
in three weeks we've got Town meetings
coming up in towns like Newbury and many
other towns in about six weeks
now part of SB 418
included a statement that
training would be offered to the
supervisors of the checklist about how
to handle people who were affected by SB
418 not having ID with them at the polls
on registration day
so for that reason and a lot of other
reasons I've been thinking about my town
meeting coming up now we've got a big
bond issue warrant article on our agenda
this year we're trying to get a library
Edition
and we've been beating the bushes trying
to get everybody who likes the library
to come out and vote for it and that
includes some people new to town
so you know the the obvious thing is go
and register so you can come to town
meeting now I realize some of you here
are from cities so you don't re you may
you know but you don't realize that we
have the election on March 14th election
of town officers and so on
often there's no competition for that in
a small town like ours
I wish I could say that I beat a lot of
people when I ran for Trustee of the
library but I didn't
I just won
but then the next night we have the
business meeting and this is the purest
form of democracy that we've got here in
New England where the budget is voted on
often with a hand count and the warrant
articles are discussed and voted on and
the library bond issue will be voted on
so I started thinking about my neighbor
who may or may not register ahead of
time and what if my neighbor decides to
register to vote brings his wife along
and vote and and comes to the polls on
that Wednesday night
and his wife doesn't have her purse has
no ID and so on
will she be given a provisional ballot
and how do we handle this at town
meeting
now of course
we we get these little colored things
that we use as ballots for the bond
issues so will those people get a
different set of different colored
little ballots
and a lot of our voting is done by a
hand count
so I'm wondering if orange mittens will
be handed out for the provisional voters
so that those votes can be discounted
later
I mean I realize this my prop is a
little bit silly here but I think there
may be some issues here
and SB 418 was passed I think without
any real need for it and so I am in
support of SB 502
to repeal us before 18 and if we could
do it before those elections that would
really be good
I'll be glad to take questions if you
have any
questions with committee
seeing none
um thank you so much thank you
uh can we have the blue sheet please I
don't have any more anybody signed up
English I don't have anyone else signed
up to speak
um I assume there's our none so with
that we'll read off this blue sheet and
get out of here
okay
uh I gotta do the math here right
oh none of them uh we had four people
signed in uh all four were for the um
bill
with that I'm going to close the uh
Committee hearing on hb502
um
I don't know if it's been announced yet
um we should be having another committee
meeting next Tuesday it should be
announced don't uh I reserve the right
to be wrong on that
um we do we have session
we have session never mind excuse me
ignore everything I said we won't be
doing that
oh yeah session on the 14th
yeah the 14th next Tuesday is the 17th
right seventh yes all right I'm gonna go
back to what I was saying because I
think it was right
um we we should yes thank thank you
representative over here is just
speaking just getting me all off my game
um wasn't much of a game to begin with
we should be having uh committee
hearings next and executive sessions
next Tuesday uh should be noticed here
shortly um if it's not it's not but I'm
like 95 certain that it's already on the
books ready to go so just as a courtesy
to the members uh with that I'll see you
all next week
closing I'm closing this committee
meeting